WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON S. B..
NINE ONE AS WE LEFT OFF ON
FRIDAY WE HAD A SERIES OF POINTS
THAT WERE LISTED. FOR THE PUBLIC
TO REVIEW.
THAT HIGHLIGHTED A DIFFERENT OF
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS.
OF WHAT THE CONFERENCE REPORT
WOULD BE MADE UP OF OVER THE
WEEKEND A STAFF SAID AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH THE
REPORT TO GO THROUGH.
AND PUT LANGUAGE AND TAXED AND
SUBSTANCE BEHIND OF THE POINTS
THAT WERE A HIGHLIGHTED --
THIS IS.
GOING TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
FEEL COMFORTABLE.
TONIGHT MAKING COMMENTS AS IT
RELATES TO THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE
MANY OF US ARE STILL MAKING OUR
WAY THROUGH IT.
HAVE A NUMBER OF COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS THAT WE
THINK NEED TO BE --
FURTHER ADDRESSED AND UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS WE HAVE ALL OF THAT.
WE'RE STILL TREATING THIS AS
WORK IN PROGRESS --
AND SOME MEMBERS I THINK FOR THE
MOST PART OR SEEN SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AND SO I WANT TO FIRST --
JUST SAY THAT.
IN MANY AREAS IN MANY RESPECTS
THEY'RE STILL THERE AND SAY --
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN WHAT.
COULD ULTIMATELY MAKE ITS WAY AS
A FINAL PRODUCT THAT COULD BE
VOTED ON BY THIS COMMITTEE.
OF THERE ARE STILL SOME ELEMENTS
--
WITHERED BE IN THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT [inaudible]
OUR SECTION.
WAR AND HOW WE DEAL WITH WAIT
GREAT RECOVERY THAT STILL HAS
ELEMENTS THAT.
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED AND
ADDRESSED CLEARLY WE UNDERSTAND
RECOGNIZE THE TIME FRAME AND SO
WE KNOW THAT BETWEEN NOW.
AND SOMETIME TOMORROW A WE WILL
HAVE TO TAKE A FINAL POSITION ON
DOCUMENT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE.
INPUT FROM I KNOW MANY OF YOU.
ARE NOW LOOKING AT IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME --
BUT WE WILL ALSO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY NIGHT. FOR FOR USE
THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT ON
ELEMENTS OF IT IS THAT YOU SEE
THAT YOU FEEL THE NEED TO SHARE
YOUR THOUGHTS.
WITH A SONG SO AS YOU CONTINUE.
TO REVIEW IT A WILL TURN TO
PUBLIC COMMENT --
HERE SHORTLY.
BUT WE WILL TO FIRST HOW TURN TO
SENATOR DODD. TO SEE IF HE HAS
ANY OPENING COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS
--
AS IT RELATES.
TO OF THE THE PROPOSAL THAT'S IN
FRONT OF GET THE A PROPOSAL THAT
--
IN FRONT OF US TODAY IS A NOT
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATOR GENERALLY.
I SEE GENERALLY --
IN AGREEMENT WITH ITS --
HIGH BRAND OF WHAT WE HAD COME
UP WITH IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
--
HAS --
INSERTED THEIR CHANGES ON IT --
I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WORK WORK WORTHY OF DISCUSSION
OR WE WOULD NOT BE HERE I DO
WHAT IT LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT
ARE.
LISTENING AND THAT THIS IS NOW
UP ON THE WEBSITE.
SO THAT IF YOU WANT TO LOOK --
AND FOLLOW ALONG --
YEAH THAT'S GREAT --
I I THINK IT YOU KNOW IT IT IN A
NUTSHELL.
WHERE WERE AT IS WERE AT A
SITUATION WHERE --
WE STILL HAVE THE SAME GOALS
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE VERY
FIRST TIME THAT WE MET.
ANYTHING THAT WE DO.
SURE PROTECT VICTIMS
[inaudible]
TODAY.
AND SHOULD ALSO HARD THE GRID SO
THAT VICTIMS THERE ARE NO
VICTIMS TOMORROW AND BEYOND.
IT SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
PROTECT RATEPAYERS TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
AND WITH ALL THE FIRES THAT
WE'VE SEEN --
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO FAR
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE --
FORREST THAT ART HELP THE THAT
HAVE TONS OF FUEL ON IT.
AND THAT TYPE OF A PROGRAM IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO THE
FINAL PRODUCT AND THEN FINALLY
FROM MY VANTAGE POINT --
HAVING HEALTHY UTILITIES --
FINANCIALLY HELP RATEPAYERS AND
I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PREMISE THAT WE'RE GONNA ALL
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH IN.
AND GET OUR ARMS AROUND I THINK
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
BECAUSE IT'S NOT --
YET.
I THINK I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT OTHERWISE RATE PAYERS
PAY MORE IN THE ABOUT.
OF CREDIT DOWNGRADES BANKRUPTCY
OR ANY OF THOSE --
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATE EVENTS
THANK.
SO LET ME IF I COULD IF.
I CAN TURN TO ANY OF THE MEMBERS
AYE WHO LET ME JUST SAY TOO THAT
I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT IN THIS --
THERE IS A AND ATTEMPT TO TO TRY
[inaudible]
TO ADDRESS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE P. YOU SEE
AND THE PURPOSES OF THE PIERCING
HAVE COME BEFORE US AND ASK.
FOR CLEARLY AND DIRECTION ON HOW
WE WOULD HAVE STRUCK THEM --
TO ADDRESS AND RESPOND TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT
BEFORE THEM CERTAINLY.
THE NEW INITIAL --
APPLICATION THERE WAS RESPONDED
TO FROM SD GENIE IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES AND HOW IF
THIS.
LEGISLATURE IS SO INCLINED TO
GIVE DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THAN WHAT THEY WERE OPERATING ON
THE STRICT LIABILITY STANDARD.
AND THE PRUDENT MANAGER
STANDARD.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
DO IS TO GIVE SOME.
A CLARITY AND SOME DIRECTION OF
THAT WOULD.
GIVE ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO THE P.
YOU SEE TO BE ABLE TO EVALUATE.
FUTURE APPLICATIONS.
IN A WAY THAT COULD TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION.
A CERTAIN CHANGES THAT ARE
EXISTING AND THE A CLIMATE.
WHETHER IT BE WIND HUMIDITY
OTHER FACTORS THAT CURRENTLY ARE
NOT CONSIDERED SO ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO ALLOW.
OF THE P. YOU SEE TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE APPLICATIONS GOING
FORWARD.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT.
A NUMBER OF ELEMENTS THAT
ADDRESS.
OF THE FUEL AS THE MY CO CHAIRS
POINTED OUT THAT IS EXISTING IN
THE FORCE THAT.
WE HAVE LOOKED --
TO OUR COLLEAGUES THE DOCTOR
WOULD AND MISTER DALI TO HELP
GIVE US SOME GUIDANCE IN TERMS
OF IMPORTING.
IMPORTANT --
ELEMENTS THAT WE THINK COULD
NEED TO BE REFLECTED IN THIS A
DOCUMENT.
A BECAUSE CLEARLY.
WE SEE THE STATE BURNING.
OF FOR MOST OF THIS YEAR
[inaudible]
AND NOT.
HAVING ANY CONNECTION.
OF THEIR WE'RE AWARE OF TO
UTILITIES.
THE CAUSE.
AND SO THERE'S AN ISSUE OUT
THERE PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED WE NEED TO GET OUR
ARMS AROUND IT AND I THINK THIS
REPORT.
ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT ANOTHER
IMPORTANT A PART OF IT IS THAT.
OF SECURITY FOR THE WORK FORCE
WORKER PROTECTION.
THERE IS AN ELEMENT IN THIS
REPORT THAT ADDRESSES WORKER
PROTECTION.
BECAUSE UNDER THE WILL WORST
CASE SCENARIO [inaudible]
AND THERE IS A BANKRUPTCY OR
SOME KIND OF A SITUATION THAT
CAUSES --
UTILITIES OUR WORKERS TO BE PUT
IN JEOPARDY WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THERE WAS LANGUAGE TO
ADDRESS THAT.
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS.
AND THERE DETAILS CERTAINLY
THERE IN THIS THAT WILL REQUIRE
US TO CONTINUE TO REVIEW.
OUR BUT WITH THAT IF THERE ARE
COMMENTS FROM ME ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATE HUESO.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU.
TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER SOME LANGUAGE.
AND I HOPE THE THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO IT SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO REVIEW THIS
AND GET BACK TO US AND TALK
ABOUT.
HOW THIS AFFECTS?
EACH AND EVERY INTEREST OUT
THERE IN OUR STATE.
THIS IS OUR OUR PROCESS INVOLVES
PUBLIC INPUT.
IT REQUIRES A A RESPONSE FROM
PEOPLE PUBLIC.
WE NEED TO HEAR.
FROM THE PUBLIC IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
WE MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS AND
AT LEAST WE WE UNDERSTAND.
WHAT ARE DECISIONS [inaudible]
OUR OUR ARE LEVERAGED AGAINST.
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN AS AS
CHAIRMAN OF ENERGY ALL THIS YEAR
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM.
ALL SIDES OF THIS ISSUE TALKING
ABOUT.
THERE THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE HAPPEN TO
STRAIGHTEN SYSTEM WHAT WE NEED
TO DO. TO IMPROVE HEALTH
CALIFORNIA'S.
RESILIENCY RELIABILITY.
AND I HEARD ALL OF THOSE FOR FOR
AN ENTIRE YEAR.
IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO THIS
MOMENT.
OF OUR ABILITY. TO DELIVER
SOMETHING TO THE PUBLIC THAT
WILL ADDRESS.
THE MOST PRESSING MATTERS FACING
US TODAY.
AND I I WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH EXAMPLES OUT
THERE [inaudible]
IN.
OUR GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT.
THEY'RE ARE WRESTLING WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS OF
ONE INCIDENT.
AND WHAT HAS IT HAS DONT DONE TO
THEIR COMMUNITY I CAN NAME.
SEVERAL BUT IN PARTICULATE I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THE EXAMPLE
OF PUERTO RICO --
UP AKON A THE COMMONWEALTH WERE.
YOU SHOULD BE A STATE.
GONNA GET INTO A CONVERSATION
BUT NO WE'RE NOT.
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE THOUGH THEY
WORK THEY WERE DEVASTATED BY THE
HURRICANE THAT TOOK OUT
[inaudible]
THEIR GRID. FOR ALMOST A YEAR.
AND THE IMPACT THAT HAD TO THAT
COMMUNITY. TO THE EXTENT THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAD LITTLE
[inaudible]
FULLY [inaudible]
THEIR HOME.
AND NEVER COME BACK.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION AND ECONOMY.
THAT IS -- A
PLACE OF ENORMOUS PROSPERITY.
FOR A VERY LARGE SEGMENT OF
AMERICA.
THIS BECOMES ALL THE MORE REAL
TO ME.
NO I THINK WE NEED TO WORK ON
SOMETHING THAT ADDRESSES.
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND I I WOULDN'T CALL THEM.
FRIVOLOUS OR OVERESTIMATED.
OR OVER EXAGGERATED.
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE EXAMPLES
ACROSS THE WORLD TO GET.
TO WHAT WE CAN EXPERIENCE HERE
IN AT SOME TO SOME DEGREE WERE
ALREADY SEEN.
SO.
I HOPE THAT.
IN OF IN OUR DELIBERATION THAT
WE WE GET THIS RIGHT.
AND IF THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANY ASPECT OF THIS.
THAT WE ONLY WORK ON THOSE PARTS
THAT WERE VERY CERTAIN OF
BECAUSE A LOT IS AT STAKE
[inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT
AND ALL THE MEMBERS.
THERE ARE COMMITTEE TO THIS
EFFORT BECAUSE IT REALLY IS.
THAT IMPORTANT AND I DON'T WANT
TO DISMISS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT I'VE HEARD.
THAT WE SHOULD NOT ACT TODAY
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY NOT THAT
IMPORTANT WE SHOULD WAIT.
NO.
WE SHOULD NOT MAKE A DECISION
THAT WILL PUT OUR STATE IN
JEOPARDY BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
WE NEED TO ACT.
ON THEM MOST PRESSING MATTERS
AFFECTING --
THIS ISSUE TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
WILL RESOLVE THIS BY THIS WEEK
AND I JUST.
WANT TO THANK THAT OPPORTUNITY
SHARE [inaudible]
PICKCENTER [inaudible]
SIR STONE.
THANK YOU UP DIDN'T MISTER
CHAIRMAN --
SOME OF US --
RECEIVED A COPY OF THE THE DRAFT
--
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MINUTES AGO
AND WELL I NEVER TOOK IN EVELYN
WOODS --
READING CLASS --
WE DID HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SCAN THE SAME PRETTY FAST AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS.
I THINK THAT ARE OUR PRIORITY
[inaudible]
SHOULD BE.
SAFEGUARDING OUR COMMUNITIES
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT --
AND PROTECTING THE REPAIRS.
AND AS A RAT IN THE DOCUMENT I
SEE SOME SICK SOME SOME ISSUES
OF OF HARDENING --
THE LINES AND A THIRD PARTY
VERIFIER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
THE UTILITIES ARE APPROPRIATELY
HARDENING THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO THE SATISFACTION OF A THIRD
PARTY --
GROUP -- AT
THE WAY I I READ IT I DON'T KNOW
IF I READ IT CORRECTLY THAT THAT
WILL BE A COSTS IS BORN TO THE
RATEPAYERS --
I'M CONCERNED THE RATE PAYERS
ARE GONNA SEE SOME SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES --
NO MATTER WHAT THE ACTIONS OF
THIS 䥡MITTEE
AND WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT A
BASIC PREMISE. TO THE P. YOU SEE
AND AUTHORIZING --
PROFIT CENTER BY FOR PROFIT --
UTILITIES THAT IT SHOULD BE AN
INCUMBENT RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
UTILITY TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE.
OPERATING SAFELY IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE STATE LAWS AND STATE
POLICIES AND AND AND AND SUBJECT
TO THIRD PARTY VERIFICATIONS --
ANOTHER CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS
THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN GET IN THERE AND DO
SENATE -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE LANGUAGE OF
SAYS THAT WE CAN GO ON TO
FEDERAL --
FORESTS THAT --
ARE.
ALREADY SUBJECT TO NIPAH WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH THE DUPLICATIVE
SEQUEL PROCESS.
I'M NOT STE I'M STILL NOT CLEAR
YET MAYBE SOMEBODY CAN.
TELL ME ABOUT HOW WE GOING TO
STATE PROPERTIES AND IF THERE'S
ANY STREAMLINING THE ALLOW US TO
FAN -- BRUSH
AND A HUNDRED TWENTY DEAD OR
DYING.
I APPRECIATE THAT WE CAN USE
SOME OF THE LOGS FOR LUMBER
RATHER THAN JUST --
BURNING THEM UP --
ANOTHER CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS
THAT -- WE
ARE GOING TO BE ALLOWING FOR
SOME.
SOME STREAMLINING AND OTHER
MITIGATING CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THROUGHOUT THE DOCUMENT I SEE A
FIVE YEAR --
WINDOW --
AFTER WHICH I THINK THINGS GO
BACK TO THE WAY THAT THEY WERE
WITCHES.
CERTAINLY HASN'T BEEN SUCCESSFUL
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN.
EMBRACE A DOCUMENT WITH A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET AND ACCOMPLISH ALL
THE GOALS THAT NEED TO BE DONE
TO MAKE THE STATE'S SAFER I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
LEAST A TEN YEAR WINDOW.
OF OF EXPEDITION --
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT --
THE P. YOU SEE --
IS GOING.
TO THE MANDATE TO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP A CLOSER
RELATIONSHIP WITH CAL FIRE TO
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN PREACHING
ABOUT.
HELLFIRE CERTAINLY HAS THE THE
EXPERTISE AND ENSURING THAT --
WIRES ARE PROPERLY --
MEDICAID AS FAR AS RUSSIAN AND
TREES AROUND THEM --
THEY NEED THEY NEED TO BE
TALKING MORE WHEN YOU WE LEARNED
WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY AUDITOR'S
THAT -- WERE
WORKING FOR THE PC TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE OF HUNDREDS
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE.
ARE ARE SAFE --
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES --
ANOTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT
YOU KNOW FOR GOING TO GET TO
SOME OF THESE MORE RURAL AREAS
WHERE YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEAD
TREES AT THERE'S A PROVISION IN
HERE THAT BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
RECRUITS IT YOU CAN HAVE A SIX
HUNDRED FOOT.
ROAD TO GET EQUIPMENT IN THERE
TO CLEAR THE TREES.
HE OTHERS ANOTHER REQUIREMENT IN
HERE THAT.
THE SIX HUNDRED FOOT ROADS
LITERALLY CANNOT BE --
CONNECTED TO ONE ANOTHER AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET DEEP --
INTO SOME OF THESE AREAS THAT
ARE INUNDATED WITH A LOT OF
THOSE DEAD TREES AND BRUSH
INAPPROPRIATELY CLEAR THEM --
TO LEASE CREATE FIREBREAKS TO
ASSURE THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE -- A
RESURGENCE IF YOU WILL OF THIS
CONTINUATION OF THIS FIRE SEASON
THAT TECHNICALLY SHOULD NOT EVEN
BE BEGUN YET.
SO WE WE MAY JUST BE BIG THAT AT
THE BEGINNING.
OF OF HER EVEN MORE HORRIFIC OF
FIRE SEASON THAT WE'VE --
WE'VE EXPERIENCED SO FAR --
I THINK THAT THE SERVING ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF ME BEING IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU AND HEARING YOUR ALL YOUR
POINTS OF VIEW --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE
SUCH A QUICK AT DEADLINE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING.
IN PRINT AND SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON PRIOR.
TO EMBRACING --
THE THE BILL --
I THINK THERE'S ENOUGH TIME TO
GET IT DONE WE'RE JUST GONNA%
HAVE TO WORK EXTRA HARD IN THE
NEXT --
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO DO IT IN
ACCORDANCE WITH.
OUR SEVENTY TWO HOUR IMPRINT
RULE WITH OUR OUR LEGISLATIVE
SESSION COMING TO AN END HERE.
THIS FRIDAY AT TWELVE O'CLOCK.
A. M. SO I LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH THE CHAIRMAN WHO
I WANT TO THANK BOTH OF THEM FOR
WORKING AS HARD.
AS THEY HAVE IN TRYING TO GET US
TO THIS POINT THIS IS NOT A
EASY.
ISSUE IT'S COMPLICATED HAS A LOT
OF MOVING PARTS AND THAT
EVERYBODY HAS VALUABLE INPUT --
EVENT THAT I RESPECT AND I'M
HOPING THAT.
BY TOMORROW THAT WE CAN ALL
RELEASE A MAJORITY OF US AGREE
THAT --
WE'RE PUTTING THE CITIZEN SAFETY
FIRST WERE.
WE'RE GOING TO APPROPRIATE
THINNING AND HARDENING OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND PROTECTING OUR REPAIRS --
IS AS BEST AS WE CAN WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME.
MAYBE PUSHING SOME UTILITIES TO
THE BRINK.
BUT NOT PUTTING THEM --
INTO A PLACE WHERE THERE
BANKRUPT AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A SERVING THE RAPE IT ALSO --
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE COMMENTS
FROM THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE.
THEY CENTER SO SIR CANNELLA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SO WE
HAVE TWENTY SIX HOURS AND FIFTY
FOUR MINUTES TO HAVE A BILL THAT
WE CAN VOTE ON BY THE INTO
SESSION.
SO THE SENATE HAS COME TO AN
AGREEMENT SO WE WANT TO REACH
YOU AGREE WITH ARE EQUAL
PARTNERS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
BUT I HOPE WE COME TO AGREEMENT
AND TWENTY SIX HOURS FIFTY FOUR
MINUTES.
OTHERWISE ALL THE WORK WE'VE
DONE IS WASTED SO I LOOK FOR
TONIGHT I HOPE WE CAN REACH AN
AGREEMENT.
WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO MEETING US ON OUR SIDE --
STYLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IN.
ALL OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE WHO
OF WEATHERED THIS SOME PROCESS I
SO I'M A FARMER AND NOT AN
ATTORNEY I HIRE ATTORNEYS WHEN I
NEED THEM TO DO CONTRACTS FOR ME
SO I DON'T IT IN TROUBLE SO I
WANT.
TO SPECIFY THAT AND ON THE GATE
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WE'VE SPENT.
MANY MANY HOURS THE LAST TWO
SUNDAYS --
ARE SIDE OF THE HOUSES THAN THE
HOUSE WE'VE BEEN WE WORKED.
FROM SEVEN O'CLOCK TILL TEN
THIRTY LAST NIGHT.
THE SUNDAY BEFORE IN THE
CHAIRMAN ASSURED ME THAT WE
WOULD BE WORKING NEXT SUNDAY'S
WHICH WAS VERY.
ENLIGHTENING TO ME SO I WANT TO
TRY TO PUT THIS IN TERMS --
THEN MAYBE YOU CAN ALL HELP ME
WITH HOW WE GET LANGUAGE.
THE PLACE BECAUSE AS I STATED
OUR FIRST HEARING THAT.
THE PEOPLE ARE DYING.
MY CONSTITUENTS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
WE TRULY HAVE HAD A CATASTROPHIC
EVENT HAPPENING CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE OVER FIVE THOUSAND HOMES
BURNED LAST YEAR. THREE WEEKS
AGO ELEVEN HUNDRED HOMES BURNED
IN MY DISTRICT.
WE HAVE A A MASSIVE.
FUEL LOADING PROBLEM
[inaudible]
SO.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT MISTER
WOULD.
AND I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FOR YEARS
NOW.
AND WE RAN BILLS.
AND WE'VE GOTTEN CLOSE AND
THEY'VE BEEN TWEAKED AT THE END
TO WHERE THEY DON'T WORK ON THE
GROUND.
BUT IT FEELS GOOD THAT YOU SAID
YOU PASSED A BILL BUT WHEN YOU
GO TO IMPLEMENT IT ON THE ACTUAL
FOR GROUND.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
SO I READ THROUGH THE FIRST
COUPLE PAGES LAST NIGHT TO SOME
OF THE LANGUAGES BEEN CROSSED.
AND I WAS SURE YOU.
THAT IT WILL NOT WORK ON THE
GROUND.
AND THERE ARE THINGS IN THERE
LIKE.
ARCHAEOLOGY ARCHEOLOGY STUDIES
AND YES WE ARGUE ALL THE STUDIES
ON WHAT WE'RE DOING TIMBER
HARVEST PRODUCTION OFF OF TWO
OFF OF TIMBER PRODUCTION ZONES
BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEBODY CLEARED A THREE HUNDRED
FOOT.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND THEIR
HOME.
BUT ONLY THAT'S NECESSARY.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET. TO THE
POINT WHERE.
WE HAVE REAL [inaudible]
STREAMLINED.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSTITUENTS
AND THOSE WHO WERE IMPACTED USE
NOW.
THE DOLLYWOOD BILL OR DOLLYWOOD
LANGUAGE.
HAS BEEN IN PRINT FOR WEEKS.
AND WE'VE SHARED THAT NO ONE A
SHARE TODAY WE HAD SOME SERIOUS
MOVEMENT --
MY STAFF HAS MET WITH THE STAFF
OF THE SENATE AND WITH ASSEMBLY
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE SEEN SOME
CHANGES COME FORTH.
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT COUPLE
WEEKS AGO DREW A LINE IN THE
SAND AND SAID.
I'M NOT MOVING UNLESS WE DO SOME
SERIOUS FUEL VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OUT THERE.
NOW WITH THAT.
WE NEED TO HAVE.
THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES.
HE ASKED FOR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND WHAT WHEN YOU GO TO PUT THAT
LANGUAGE THERE'S BLUE POLLS HAVE
HOW YOU CAN NOT GET THAT
LANGUAGE DONE AND THERE'S LOTS
OF PROBLEMS WITH THAT AND I GET
THAT.
BUT TO DO STREAMLINING AND NOT
PUTTING MONEY WITH IT IS DOING A
DISSERVICE TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BURNING UP OUT THERE.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
STREAMLINED WE WANNA PUT SOME
SERIOUS RESOURCES IN THEIR
BECAUSE WE ARE MEETING MORE
CARBON AND WE ARE BURNING PEOPLE
UP AND WE'RE NOT GONNA DO IT AT
THE PATIENTS GO WE NEED TO DO IT
AT IF WE DON'T.
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS
SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE ON ON FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND NOT JUST FORCE MAYBE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU.
STREAMLINING PROCESSES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR THOSE
WHO LIVE.
IN AN AREA WHERE THERE'S AN
ACTUAL TREE THAT HOUSE OF VALUE
IT.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA NEED THE MONEY
AS MUCH AS SOMEBODY WHO LIVES.
IN AN AREA WHERE IT'S BRUSH.
AND THAT A LOT OF THIS STATE
THEY'RE GONNA NEED.
THE RESOURCES TO GO AHEAD AND
MANAGE A BRUSH BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
JUST PUT FIRE IN IT IT AND THAT
YOU'RE GONNA MANAGER WITH WITH
THE MATCH.
SO I WOULD JUST MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR THE SECOND PART I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS THAT.
WE'VE HAD BECAUSE WE WERE IN
THIS HEARING BECAUSE OF FIRE
NUMBER.
ONE AND THE NUMBER TWO THING
WERE AND YEARS BECAUSE ONE OUT
OF TEN FIRES [inaudible]
ARE STE INDICTED BY [inaudible]
UTILITIES.
AND WE HAVE A HUGE A LIABILITY
IN THE WAY WE'RE STRUCTURED
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE IF YOU'RE LIABLE.
IN ANY POOR THAT IN ANY PORTION
OF THAT.
YOU'RE THE YOU'RE YOU PAY IF
YOUR UTILITY THAT CAUSED SOME
FIRE YOU PAY AND THAT GETS
PUSHED OFF.
TO UTILITY AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
IN THE US THE GENIE CASE WHERE
THEY WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS.
AND THERE'S THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS OWED AND THE P.
YOU SEE SAID.
YOU'RE GONNA PAY IT AND I'M FINE
WITH THAT.
I'M OKAY WITHOUT THAT'S THE
PROCESS THAT.
WAS IN PLACE.
BUT NOW THAT WE'VE HAD THESE
EXTREME CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
WE HAVE UTILITY OTHER P. GINNY.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
WITHSTAND THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM THESE FIRES BECAUSE
UNDER THAT RULING.
THEY WILL BE THEY WILL BE HELD A
100% ACCOUNTABLE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID.
HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD AND HOW
DO WE SAY? TO ALL OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT.
THE INVESTORS NEED TO PAY.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE.
INVESTORS NEED TO HAVE SKIN IN
THE GAME AND SO.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU PUT
THIS IN LANGUAGE BUT I'M JUST
GOING TO SHARE WITH YOU WHAT I
THINK.
WOULD BE A PROCESS THAT WOULD.
ALLOW US TO GET WHERE WE NEED TO
GO.
AND IT WOULD HELD HARMLESS.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO BE
HELD HARMLESS I THINK WE SHOULD.
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN FIRES [inaudible]
WE SHOULD.
TELL THE UTILITY. TO PAY THE THE
INVESTORS TO PAY AS MUCH ADD TO
A POT OF MONEY.
THAT THEY CAN IF THEY CAN AFFORD
WITHOUT GOING BANKRUPT.
SO LET'S JUST PICK A NUMBER.
LETS SAY THAT THEY DID A STRESS
TEST ON THEIR E. ON THERE AND
THE THEY CAN PAY. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ALL THIS ON PICKING A
NUMBER OF HOPE IT'S SIX AND WE
PUT OUT A POT AND WE SAY TO
THEM.
NOBODY GOES INTO A POT AND IT
AND IT STAYS IN THAT POT AND WE
DON'T CHANGE ANY OF THE RULES
FOR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO
FOR TWO THOUSAND HEAVY FOR YOUR
JUST LIKE AS THE GENIE.
YOU'RE LIABLE YOU PAY YOU PAY UP
FRONT SO YOU'VE TAKEN DOWN WHERE
THEY'RE NOT BANKRUPT YOU TAKEN
ALL THE RESOURCES.
AND YOU PUT IN THAT PART.
SO THAT TAKES CARE OF THEM NOT
BEING BAKER EARLY THAT WOULD
PREVENT BANKRUPTCY BUT WE'RE
PUTTING THAT TO THE SIDE THEN
MOVING FORWARD FROM.
TWO THOUSAND FROM JANUARY ONE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FORWARD IF
WE PASSED SOME.
FORWARD WE WOULD SAY.
WE WOULD GIVE SOME DIRECTION TO
THE P. YOU SEE.
WHO TELL THE PEACE P. YOU SEE?
WE'RE GONNA DO WHILE WE'RE GONNA
FIRST OF ALL WE WOULD DO THE
FUEL MANAGEMENT WE PUT MONEY
WITH THAT THAT SOMEONE NUMBER.
TWO WE WOULD TELL THE PC LOOK.
WE'RE HARD UP THE LINES WE'RE
GOING TO VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
AND IF.
YOU ARE AT FAULT.
MR UTILITY WHOEVER YOU ARE OUT
THERE FROM JANUARY ONE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FORWARD.
IF YOU ARE LIABLE.
AND YOU AND LENDS LESS YOU GIVE
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN.
MISTER WOODS DISTRICT WERE A
TREE BLEW LAMB BLUE FROM OUTSIDE
THEIR CLEAR ZONE THEY DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT AND IT BLEW
INTO THEIR TREE.
AND BECAUSE THE FIRE.
SO THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO RIGHT WE'VE TOLD
THEM TO HARDEN UP THEIR SYSTEM.
BUT IT IT HIT THE LINES OF THE
LINE BECAUSE THE FIRE SO WE
WOULD SAY THAN WE WOULD GIVE
SOME PARAMETERS TO PC FOR THE P.
C. TO BE ABLE TO SAY.
WELL THEY DID EVERYTHING RIGHT.
THEY'VE TRIED TO PROTECT THEIR
RATE PAYERS THEY DID EVERYTHING
IN THEIR INNATE IN THEIR POWER
BUT YOU KNOW NOT TO GOD LET THIS
LINE THERE.
SO THERE 10% LIABLE THEIR 50%
LIABLE THERE IF THERE ARE SOME.
A FORMULA THAT COMES UP WITH
SAYS THEY'RE LIABLE AND FOR
WHATEVER AMOUNT THEY'RE LIABLE
FOR THEY PAY.
AND WHATEVER AMOUNT THEY'RE NOT
LIABLE FOR IT HAS TO BE PASSED
ON THE RATEPAYERS.
AND THAT'S HOW WE WOULD GIVE
THEM SECURITY TO MOVE FORWARD
AND ALLOW THEM TO RECOUP.
THAT'S IN MY MIND A PROCESS.
HOW YOU PUT IT INTO WORDS I HAVE
A LOT OF WORDS I WANT TO PUT
INTO THE FORCE MEASURE EXACTLY
UNDERSTAND THAT?
BUT THE OTHER PIECES I NEED SOME
HELP WITH MISTER CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
JEFF.
WELL THANK YOU --
AND YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING AT
THIS LATE STAGE HOME LITERALLY
LAID IT'S NINE FIFTEEN IN THE
EVENING --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS AND I KNOW WE WE DO THIS
OFTEN BUT I I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT WE ANITA.
BUG GIVE A LOT OF PRAISE TO OUR
CO CHAIRS DON'T BECAUSE BOTH OF
THEM HAVE DONE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNTS OF WORK ON THIS.
OTHER STYLES ARE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT --
MAYBE JUST A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT YOU GUYS CAN LAUGH
IT'S OKAY --
BUT THERE IT WE'VE ACTUALLY I
THINK GOT TO A PLACE WHERE SOME
REALLY GOOD WORK I'M HAS HAS
BEEN DONE.
I'LL LAST NIGHT SO.
WE ENDED UP HAVING A MEETING
AMONGST THE ASSEMBLY --
CONFEREES AND WE ARE PRESENTED
WITH A SOME LANGUAGE LAST NIGHT
AND WE HAD LOTS OF ROBUST
CONVERSATION.
A LAST NIGHT THEM ALTHOUGH AFTER
SEVERAL HOURS AND DRIVING ALL
DAY COMING UP I GOT A LITTLE --
MAYBE A LITTLE DELIRIOUS.
AND SO I WOKE UP THIS MORNING
AND WANTED TO PUT SOME THINGS --
TO PAPER AND I KNOW THAT --
THAT OF SOME OF THEM WERE DALLY
LEADER DALLY --
HAD JUST TALKED ABOUT A FEW OF
THESE THINGS ONE OF THE THINGS
IT'S IMPORTANT IS FOR US TO TO
NOT JUST.
SPEAK ABOUT ALSO BUT THE TO
LISTEN AND TO KIND OF GET A
SENSE OF WHERE.
WHERE EVERYBODY NOW IS THAT?
I'M LAST NIGHT I DIDN'T DO A
WHOLE LOT OF LISTENING AND A LOT
OF TALKING BUT AFTER ON THIS
MORNING A GOING OVER THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PRESENTED TO
US LAST NIGHT.
AND THERE WERE IT WAS NOT WHAT I
EXPECTED IT TO BE LAST LAST
EVENING ACTUALLY THINK THE
LANGUAGE.
THAT WAS IN OUR IN NINETY EIGHT
IS ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD AND I'M
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE I'M
TALKING TO IT ABOUT WHAT'S IN
THE LIABILITY --
ON VEGAS NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
PAGE THIRTY FIVE PAGE THIRTY SIX
AND AND ALSO.
WHAT'S IN THE DOOR AND ON A
NINETY SIX WE JUST RECEIVED THAT
THIS EVENING THERE ARE SOME
REALLY GOOD.
I LANGUAGE IN THAT REGARD
REGARDS TO CREATING A REASON
WEST REASONABLE A STANDARD.
I WONDER THOUGH --
AND WE TALKED ABOUT A THAT
REASONABLE STANDARD BUT IF WE DO
IF IT'S THAT THERE'S AN APPETITE
AMONGST --
THAT THIS --
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. TO BE ABLE
TO SEPARATE WHAT HAPPENED --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WHAT'S WHAT
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY ANA ON A
GOING FORWARD BASIS.
AND SO THIS MORNING I'M AYE
ALONG WITH THEM SOME STAFF WERE
TALKING AT THE IN PUTTING SOME
THINGS AT THE PAPER AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN BECAME A FOUR POINT PLAN
--
AND THEN LATER ON THIS AFTERNOON
THAT BECOMING THE MAYES PLANET
PREFER NOT TO BE CALLED THE
MAYES PLEDGES TO HIS TO REALLY.
BUT
WHICH WAS.
IF YOU KNOW THE FIRST PART OF
THAT WOULD BE AND I THINK YOU
GOT A COPY IN FRONT OF YOU.
BUT WOULD BE THAT THE DOLLYWOOD
REGULATION AT CHANGES IN REGARDS
TO OUR FORCE MANAGEMENT AND FIRE
PREVENTION OF THE SECOND PART OF
IT WOULD BE --
MAKING SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY
FUND THAT --
THAT FED FORCE MANAGEMENT AND IN
FIRE PREVENTION AND IN THE THIRD
ONE WOULD BE DEALING WITH OUR
PAST INCIDENTS WHICH WE ALL KNOW
THAT TO BE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER WE NEED TO
SECURE TIES WITH A STRESS TEST.
AND MAKING SURE THAT
SHAREHOLDERS NAM BEAR THE BRUNT
BECAUSE THERE IS SOME LIABILITY
--
THAT'S THERE BEFORE RATE PAYERS
WOULD PROVIDE I'M ANY COVER UP
FOR THEM AND UNDER THAT OLD RULE
WE WOULD USE THE EXISTING
PRUDENT MANAGE MANAGER STANDARD
I'M EXISTING UPROOTED MANAGER
STANDARD.
AT ON THE FOURTH AND FINAL THING
IS IN REGARDS TO FUTURE
INCIDENTS AND THAT WOULD BE A
DEALING WITH A COST RECOVERY.
A MAKING SURE THAT FAULT THIS IS
PEOPLE ARE PAYING FOR THEIR
FAULT THAT THE SHAREHOLDERS
WOULD BE ON THE HOOK IF.
A THERE WAS A ANY LIABILITY THAT
WAS CAUSED BY --
THE THAT THAT THE COMPANIES.
A BUT IF THOSE THINGS THEY
WANTED FAULT.
THAT THAT WOULD THAT COULD BE
PASSED ALONG A TO TO RATEPAYERS
AND I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S ANY
--
ANY STOMACH AT ALL AMONGST THIS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THOSE THINGS AND MAYBE MAKE
SOME CHANGES I'VE ACTUALLY THIS
EVENING PEOPLE ARE PASSING ME --
LANGUAGE THIS EVENING AS I WAS
WALKING IN AND THINKING HEY
THAT'S A PRETTY DECENT PLAN THAT
MAY THERE'S THERE'S A FEW LITTLE
TWEAKS THAT THAT COULD BE ADDED
--
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO REWRITE
THE WHOLE ARE IN WHICH IF YOU
LITTLE TWEAKS THAT COULD BE MADE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE SO I
JUST WANTED TO OFFER THAT.
THANK YOU MISS REYES
[inaudible]
THAT WOULD.
OR THINK OF IT THANK SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIRS AND OFFERED
THE TIME THEY'VE INVESTED AND
AND ACTUALLY QUITE FRANKLY FOR
PUTTING UP WITH SOME OF US --
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THESE DISCUSSIONS --
I WAS TROUBLED [inaudible]
BECAUSE WHILE WE HAVE WE HAVE
UTILITIES WE HAVE --
WE HAVE INSURANCE COMPANIES WE
HAD --
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING VICTIMS
--
WE HAVE OUR OUR OUR WORKERS WHO
WORK WITH UTILITIES.
THE ISSUE THAT WAS A REALLY
BEING DISCUSSED MUCH WAS VICTIMS
--
DIRECTLY I MEAN THEY WERE THEY
WERE BEING DISCUSSED BUT THEY
CERTAINLY WERE AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST.
AND THAT FRUSTRATED ME.
THANK ONCE --
THE DECISION WAS MADE TO REMOVE
INVERSE CONDEMNATION FROM THE
DISCUSSION --
WE SAW THAT IT THERE SEEM TO BE
A PATHWAY FOR THE VICTIMS AND
THAT THAT PLEASED ME AND I THINK
THAT THAT THAT IS THE RIGHT
THING THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
ISSUES THAT REPRESENT MY BOTTOM
LINE OR AS I HAVE WRITTEN IN THE
PRESS -- MY
LINE IN THE SAND --
I THINK IT IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
REGULATORY CHANGES TO FACILITATE
FIRE PREVENTION.
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AND THE LANGUAGE IN THE PROPOSAL
IS CLOSE IN MANY WAYS.
AND I THINK WE CAN GET THERE.
BUT THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS
AND SOMETIMES A SINGLE WORD OR
TO MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
CURRENTLY IN.
MY DISTRICT OR PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT THERE'S A FIRE BURNING.
A CALL THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX AND
TODAY.
THE LATEST REPORTS ARE THAT IT
IS AT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES.
NOW THAT IS MORE THAN 50% LARGER
THAN THE LAST PREVIOUS LARGE
FIRE WHICH WAS THE THOMAS FIRE
AND AND SENATOR JACKSON'S
DISTRICT. TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND ACRES HAVE BURNED IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLIES DISTRICT
DESTROYING A THOUSAND OVER A
THOUSAND HOMES AND THAT FIRE IS
STILL BURNING AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S FOR COMPLETELY
CONTAINED.
IT'S VERY CLOSE.
CLEARLY WE HAVE AN ISSUE.
OVER A MILLION ACRES IS BURNT
ARE READY THIS YEAR AND WE
HAVEN'T HIT SEPTEMBER FIRST.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT HE AND I
FOR QUITE AWHILE.
AND I WILL NEVER FORGET MY VERY
FIRST YEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY
LISTENING TO BRIAN ON THE VERY
LAST NIGHT OF SESSION.
SAY I'M WORRIED ABOUT FIRE I'M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT FIRE.
I CAN REMEMBER EXACTLY WHAT HE
SAID.
BUT I DO REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
THE NEXT DAY.
AND A MAJOR WILDFIRE BROKE OUT
LAKE COUNTY.
AND THAT'S WAS THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEN HERE.
THAT HAD THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES.
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING FUNDING FOR PREVENTION
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
A CURRENTLY THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
BEFORE US.
PROVIDES FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
NOT BEEN ASKING FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I DIDN'T
PULL THAT NUMBER OUT OF THE AIR.
THAT NUMBER CAME [inaudible]
FROM.
ESSENTIALLY FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S REPORT IN APRIL ASKING
FOR TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION.
I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE LIGHT.
AND I THINK THERE'S OTHER THINGS
THAT WE NEED AS WELL.
I'M LOOKING FOR LANGUAGE.
AND I KNOW WHAT THOSE WORDS ARE.
THE GUARANTEE THIS FUNDING.
AND I'D.
I'D DIE DON'T THINK I CAN SETTLE
FOR LESS THAN THAT.
I WANT TO GUARANTEE WE DESERVE
THE GUARANTEE CALIFORNIA.
DESERVES A GUARANTEE TO THAT
WE'RE GOOD DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT PROPERTY AND MAKE
PEOPLE SAFE IN THE STATE.
PART OF THIS WE SHOULD ALSO BE
CONSIDERING HOW ENSURE THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS.
HAVE THE TOOLS AND THE ASSETS.
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THEM.
AND MAKE THEIR JOB SAFER AS
WELL.
NOT BEEN ROUND AND ROUND ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW WE LOOK AT THAT THE
THE PAST FIRES AND YOU NO I BEEN
I I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
CHANGING THE RULES FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THIS THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE US
TALKS ABOUT A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO --
TO BE CONSIDER FOR THE PC TO
POTENTIALLY CONSIDER.
HOW THE LIABILITY MIGHT BE
PARCELED OUT IN THE FUTURE?
BUT A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT WOULD INFLUENCE THAT
DECISION.
WORK DONE.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THEIR WORK DONE.
AND I THINK I THINK I THINK THAT
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT A LOT
OF A HARDENING.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR SIMPLY
DOESN'T EXIST.
I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED SOME SORT OF A TEST.
THEY MAKE SURE THAT SHAREHOLDERS
PAY FIRST.
THAT RATE PAYER INCREASES THAT
ARE NEEDED AFTER THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE ENOUGH MONEY --
WITH WITH THE UTILITIES.
AND WE SHOULD FIND A WAY THAT WE
SECURE TIES THAT WAR OR SPREAD
OUT SO THAT THE PAIN IS SMALL.
OVER A TWENTY YEAR PERIOD AND
I'D LOVE TO KNOW AT SOME POINT
THE NUMBERS ON THAT WITH HOW
THAT WORKS OUT.
BUT PART OF THAT ALSO HAPPENS TO
BE.
THAT WE PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD THOSE ANY RATE
INCREASES AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIGURE THAT GOING FORWARD.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT THE
PROCESS LAID OUT IN THIS IN THIS
DOCUMENT THAT LOOK THAT THAT
CONSIDERS OTHER ISSUES GOING
FORWARD LIKE.
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
LIKE NGUYEN LIKE HUMIDITY LIKE
ALL THOSE THINGS ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
[inaudible]
AFTER.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE GRID
HARDENING WE NEED.
AND THAT GRID HARDENING
SHOULDN'T.
WAIT UNTIL WE GO THROUGH A P.
YOU SEE RATE MAKING PROCESS THAT
SHOULD START RIGHT AWAY.
AND NOT ONLY SHOULD START RIGHT
AWAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MONEY THAT'S BEING COLLECTED
FROM RATEPAYERS TO DO THAT IS
ACTUALLY SPENT A PROPERTY.
AND WE OUGHT AUDIT MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT HAPPENS.
AND YOU KNOW HOW WE GET TO THE
REST OF THIS YOU KNOW THROUGH IN
THE NEXT [inaudible] TWENTY HOW
MUCH TIME SENATOR CANNELLA.
YEAH WHATEVER.
YEAH THIS IS LESS TIME THEM
FORCES THAT WE SAID BEFORE --
IN THIS IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME IS --
IS IS IS IS THE CHALLENGE AND
SO.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT I WON HERE
WITH THE REST MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
TO SAY AND WELL LOOK FOR TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION [inaudible]
SENATE MARIA'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO
WANT TO THANK OUR TWO CHAIRS.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE PUT THEM.
AND AS SOON Y. COLLEAGUES SAID
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING UP WITH
THE REST OF THEM.
IT OF THAT IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES MENTIONED THAT HE DROVE UP
FOR SEVEN HOURS WE'VE SPENT TWO
SUNDAYS HERE.
YESTERDAY WE DID RECEIVE.
THE LANGUAGE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT IN THE
ABSTRACT.
I THEN WENT HOME AND FOR THE
NEXT FOUR HOURS.
READ THROUGH THE ENTIRE
LANGUAGE.
AND MADE SOME NOTES FOR MYSELF.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK BUT IT'S
BEEN IMPORTANT WORK AND ITS BEEN
COMMENTED ON THAT THIS IS
EXACTLY WHY WE COME HERE.
THE COMMITTEE HAVE SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS DISCUSSING AND
DELIBERATING.
THE ISSUES WITHIN ITS PURVIEW.
THE TOPICS OF LEAD TO A CRITICAL
QUESTION FOR THIS COMMITTEE.
WHAT IN THIS SITUATION IS THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE?
IS OUR ROLE MOVING FORWARD
[inaudible]
SAVE. FOR A BAILOUT A
BUSINESSWOMAN HAVE ARGUABLY
MISMANAGED THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES. FOR ME THE
ANSWER IS NO.
I'VE ALSO HEARD A DESIRE BY SOME
TO ADDRESS THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES.
FRANKLY AS NOTED BY MY
COLLEAGUE.
THE REPORTS ON THESE FIRES HAVE
NOT BEEN COMPLETED.
TODAY WE DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT
OF FAULT FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRES.
NOR THE TOTAL COST AFTER
SETTLEMENTS PAYOUTS. TO BE
CLEAR.
WE MUST HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THOSE
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE.
WE WILL NOT ENGAGE IN A BAILOUT.
BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT THOUGH IS
OUR ROLE AS LEGISLATURE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SECURITY
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND THIS HAS BEEN JEOPARDIZED
BECAUSE OF THE DEVASTATION
CAUSED.
BY THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
SOME OF THE STATISTICS AND I
THINK.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER THESE WE
NEED TO IT WHAT WE NEED TO PUT
THIS ALL INTO PERSPECTIVE.
OR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONE OF
THE STATISTICS SHOWS THAT THE
COST HAS BEEN OVER THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
THERE'VE BEEN A TOTAL OF OVER
NINE THOUSAND FIRES. FIVE
THOUSAND HOMES BURNED. FORTY ONE
DEATHS [inaudible]
CIVILIAN DEATHS.
PLUS TWO FIREFIGHTERS LOST THEIR
LIVES.
NON FATAL INJURIES INCLUDE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
CIVILIANS AND TWELVE
FIREFIGHTERS.
THERE'S MUCH THAT WE NEED TO DO.
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING.
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED.
I HAVE SAID FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING THE NUMBER ONE THING
THAT I WANT TO DEAL WITH IS
MAKING SURE THAT ARE VICTIMS ARE
MADE WHOLE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE SAFETY
AND PROTECTION [inaudible]
THE FUTURE [inaudible]
HARDENING.
AND I LIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
REALLY AT I REALLY AM RELYING ON
MY COLLEAGUES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S IT WOULD AND
DOLLY. TO GIVE US MORE DETAILS
ON THAT.
WE DO HAVE A FARMER IN OUR
MIDST.
AND WE DO HAVE TO TAKE.
HIS LEAD ON SOME OF THESE
THINGS.
STEP STAFF DRAFT.
THAT MANY OF YOUR HOPEFULLY ALL
OF YOU [inaudible]
SEEN.
IT'S NOT A COMPLETE OR PERFECT
DOCUMENT.
pMUST BE MADE IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WE MUST PRIORITIZE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT NOW.
WE MUST ADDRESS AND CLARIFY THE
RULES OF ASSESSING CASES OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES MOVING
FORWARD.
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR
WORKERS WHO RISK BEING DISPLACED
DUE TO NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
I WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
EVALUATE THE POLICY LANDSCAPE.
IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE NO SINGLE ACTION WILL
PERMANENTLY FIX THIS PROBLEM.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT
WE'RE HERE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE ACTIONS ULTIMATELY TAKEN
BY THIS COMMITTEE.
MUST REFLECT THAT COMMITMENT.
I AM ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
THIS AND I KNOW THAT YOU ALL
HAVE WORKED VERY HARD THIS IT'S
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE HONOR WORKING
WITH EVERYBODY BECAUSE THE
COMMITMENT.
A GENUINE COMMITMENT FROM ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CLEAR.
WE KNOW WE WANT TO DO SOMETHING
WE KNOW WE WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
STATE STABILITY.
I THINK GETTING THERE I THINK
WHAT WHERE THERE MAY BE SOME
DISAGREEMENTS ON EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED TO DO ON ALL THE DETAILS AS
IT HAS BEEN SAID.
THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS.
BUT I AM ABSOLUTELY IT READY TO
WORK FOR THE NEXT TWENTY SIX
HOURS.
SO THAT WE'RE SURE TO GET
SOMETHING TO PRINT.
AND BE ABLE TO VOTE ON IT ON
FRIDAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR JACKSON.
WELL SINCE I STARTED THIS OFF
YESTERDAY I GUESS HOLES.
FINISH IT OFF AT LEAST THIS
FIRST ROUND TODAY --
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PREVENTION AND
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SAFETY.
A I ACTUALLY YESTERDAY SAT DOWN
AND READ TO HIM.
HE GOT WRENCHING FOUR PAGE
LETTER.
FROM A WOMAN IN MY DISTRICT --
WHO LOST HER HUSBAND AND HER
SON?
IN THE DEBRIS FLOW AND TERM HER
SON'S SOME BODY IS YET TO BE
FOUND.
AND THE FACT THAT BOTH SHE AND
HER SURVIVING DAUGHTER.
ALONG WITH THE HUSBAND IN THE
SUN WERE BLOWN OUT OF THEIR HOME
LITERALLY IS THE HILLSIDE ABOVE
MACHITO HOME CAME DOWN --
THEY LOST THEIR DOGS WELL.
AND THE TRAUMA I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF YOU SAW BUT THERE WERE
PHOTOS AND A SCENARIO OF A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL THAT THEY
I RECOVERED.
AYE IN THAT TO BRIEF LOW WHO
JUST ABOUT DROWNED BUT
MIRACULOUSLY FOUND A POCKET OF
AIR.
AND THAT WAS HER DAUGHTER.
AND SHE HERSELF WAS HOSPITALIZED
FOR THREE WEEKS --
AND BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM THE
SCARS ARE SO DEEP.
THAT SHE'S HAD TO QUIT HER HER
JOB.
BECAUSE FOR DAUGHTER IS SO
TRAUMATIZED THAT SHE LITERALLY
CAN'T BE LEFT ALONE.
IT'S OUR SHARE THIS WITH YOU
BECAUSE WE CANNOT FORGET THE
HUMAN ELEMENT OF WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE LOSE THEIR LOVED
ONES AND I WON'T EVEN GO INTO
WHAT AN EXTRAORDINARY FAMILY
THIS WAS --
SO I LOOK AT THIS FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE I KNOW WE ALSO NEED
TO LOOK AT IT --
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF KEEPING
ELECTRICITY GOING KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON KEEPING PEOPLE WORKING
IN.
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY --
IMPORTANTLY REFERENCED HERE BUT
THIS IS REALLY ARE IN MANY
RESPECTS ABOUT THE SAFETY IN THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA --
BECAUSE FIRES HAVE BEEN BURNING
WILL CONTINUE TO BURN ALL OVER
THE STATE IN THE RURAL AREAS IN
THE URBAN AREAS [inaudible]
FROM FROM BEVERLY HILLS TO
TAMANA SETO INVENTOR AND TO THE
SANTA ROSA AND LAKE COUNTY IN
AYE EVERYWHERE DOWN TO SAN DIEGO
SO.
WE DO HAVE A AN ENORMOUS
RESPONSIBILITY AND I THINK WE
DON'T KNOW A A PRETTY GOOD JOB
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE ISSUES
I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
SOME OF THE APPROACHES.
TO TO GETTING RID OF SOME OF THE
TREASON AND THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON BUT I THINK THAT
TOGETHER WE CAN COME TO SOME
KIND OF COMPROMISE NOBODY IS
GOING TO BE REALLY HAPPY THIS IS
NOT A HAPPY SITUATION.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
GETTING EXCITED AND CELEBRATING
WITH GLASSES OF CHAMPAGNE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROTECTING.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO --
I THINK WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE --
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE
BUT I THINK THE ISSUE THE ONE
MAJOR ISSUE OUT STANDING IN AND
I AGREE WITH THIS AS I DON'T
WANT TO REWARD OR LET.
THOSE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING LESS THAN WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE DOING YOU KNOW OUR UTILITIES
--
THEIR PRIVATELY OWNED DOG I
GRANT YOU THAT BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE A MISSION.
THEY ALSO RESPONSIBILITY TO
PEOPLE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THEIR MONOPOLY WE HAVE GIVEN
THEM THAT ABILITY AND I THINK
MANY OF US ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED
THAT THEY HAVEN'T NECESSARILY
TAKE IN THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
A CAREFULLY AND ARE HONESTLY.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE NEED THOSE
COMPANIES ARE WE NEED SOME FORM
OF COMPANY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE ELECTRICITY THAT IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE STATE.
AND TO OUR EXISTENCE AT THIS
POINT TIME AS WE BEGIN HELL ARE
SO DEPENDENT UPON IT.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS.
HOW DO WE?
ARE SURE THAT THAT ELECTRICITY
CAN.
TO AT THE SAME TIME ASSURING
THAT THOSE RESPONSIBLE THAT
BEFORE THE MISSION OF BOTH
PROVIDING THAT ELECTRICITY AND
SECURING.
A THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE IN A WAY
THAT IS GOING TO LIMIT TO THE
EXTENT HUMANLY POSSIBLE THESE
EVENTS WHERE I HAVE TO READ
ABOUT MY CONSTITUENTS WHO.
LOST THEIR LIVES MY MY M.
GRANDDAUGHTER --
WAS IN CLASS WITH THIS YOUNG MAN
AND THEY HAVE LEFT HIS SEAT
VACANT.
I IN HIS MEMORY --
FOR THE LAST YEAR --
WE ARE A STATE OF PEOPLE.
AND SO I THINK OUR FIRST
PRIORITY HAS TO BE TO OUR
PEOPLE.
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE OF HOW ARE WE GOING TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT ARE THE COSTS AND THE
LIABILITIES.
FOR A IN THAT BET PARTICULARLY
PGN IN I WOULD POSIT THAT EDISON
WILL HAVE LIABILITY IN MY
DISTRICT FOR THE FIRES THAT
OCCURRED [inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE TO ASK THE COURT WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO. TO
TAKE WHAT WE CAN FROM THE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE PROFITED BY
THEIR PROFLIGATE BEHAVIOR.
BY THEIR WILLINGNESS TO GIVE
HUGE PROFITS IT --
ARE SHOULD SAVE --
GIVE BONUSES TO THEIR CEO'S --
FOR THE PROFITS THEY HAVE
INCURRED A IN RECEIVED AT THE AT
THE EXPENSE OF CLEARING OUT
THERE AREAS IN DOING THINGS THAT
WOULD HARDEN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE --
YET AT THE SAME TIME OUGHT NOT
IMPACTING THE REPAIRS TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN AVOID THAT.
AND YET WHAT I'M HEARING IN I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE AND I
WANNA SEE THE NUMBERS.
WE HERE FROM PEACHY NEITHER
THREATS OF GOING BANKRUPT ARE
HAVING THEIR THAT CREDIT RATING
REDUCE THAT MAY BE TRUE --
I WANT TO SEE THE NUMBERS
BECAUSE I I'M NOT SURE I'M
CONVINCED THAT PEACHY ISN'T
THAT.
THE A PRECIPICE OF BANKRUPTCY
THEY'VE MADE WHAT WAS A FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN PROFITS OVER THE FIRST
QUARTER OF THIS YEAR THEY
CONTINUE TO DO WELL AND THAT'S
JUST FINE [inaudible]
BUT THOSE PROFITS HAVE TO COME
BACK.
AND WE NEED TO AYE I GUESS SO
THE SENATOR DODD REFERS TO IT AS
A SCRUB MEANING TAKE THOSE
PROFITS.
AND WE NEED TO USE THOSE PROFITS
TO PAY FOR THE FOR THE
MISGUIDED.
PROFIT DRIVEN MOTIVES THAT HAVE
CAUSED.
AND MANY OF US. TO TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE THE TRAGEDY IN OUR
DISTRICT AND AND THE IMPACT IT'S
HAD ON OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND SO I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
DOING THAT.
THE PROFITS HAVE TO COME BACK.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS WELL.
IS IT SUFFICIENT.
AND SO THAT'S WHEN WE GET INTO
THIS WHOLE QUESTION OF
SECURITIZATION.
AND IF YOU SECURITIZED WHO ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO PAY FOR
THAT IT'S THE SURE IT'S THE
RIGHT PAYER.
AND I ASK WELL WHO ELSE.
COULD WE LOOK TO FOR THIS.
AND I AND I'M NOT SURE DETERGENT
ANSWER [inaudible]
SOME.
YOU KNOW I'D LOVE TO GET THAT
MONEY BACK FROM THE CEOS AND
OTHERS WHO CAVALIERLY FELT THAT
THEY WERE ENTITLED TO ALL THESE
BONUSES.
FOR ESSENTIALLY --
MAKING ALL THIS MONEY AT THE
EXPENSE OF OUR COMMUNITIES BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT CERTAINLY ISN'T
GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
SO I THINK --
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO THE P. YOU
SEE.
THEY HAVE A ROLE HERE WHETHER WE
LIKE IT OR NOT THEY TO HAVE A
RULE -- I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DO WHAT THEIR SUPPOSED TO
DO.
AND AND LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
FACTORS AND I FOR ONE AM NOT
PARTICULARLY EXCITED ABOUT
CHANGING THE RULES NOW
[inaudible]
RETROACTIVELY.
I THINK THAT THEY NEED TO APPLY
THE SAME STANDARD SHOULD THEY
HAVE BEEN APPLYING PERHAPS GOING
FORWARD WE CAN HELP GIVE THEM
GUIDANCE.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE GOT TO DO THEIR
JOB THEY GOTTA STEP UP.
AND I THINK ARE WE NEED TO SEND
THE SIGNAL TO THE MARKETS --
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS.
ABOUT HOLDING THESE COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME RECOGNIZING THAT WE NEED
ELECTRICITY.
AND I THINK WE NEED --
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT NOT AS AN
EXCUSE AND I THINK THIS IS WHERE
SOME OF US HAVE A CONCERN.
WE'VE ALL KNOWN CLIMATE CHANGE
WAS HAPPENING.
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS HAD IMPACTS
IT SHOULD NOT BE AN EXCUSE BUT A
MOTIVATION [inaudible]
A MOTIVATION.
IT HAS TO BE FACTORED IN BY
THESE UTILITIES.
THE CANCER ALL WELL CLIMATE
CHANGES HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM SO
THEREFORE YOU KNOW DON'T HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE.
NO YOU HAVE TO FACTOR CLIMATE
CHANGE INTO THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING YOU HAVE TO HARDEN THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'VE GOTTA BE
OUT THERE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
LIMBS OF TREES.
THAT COULD BLOW IT IN EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED MILE AN HOUR WIND
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HAVING
WE'RE NOT GONNA GIVE YOU A PASS
FOR THAT AND I THINK THAT'S PART
OF WHAT MANY OF US.
ARE FEELING THE FRUSTRATION IN
THE HUNDREDS OF LETTERS THAT
MANY OF US I BELIEVE HAVE BEEN
GETTING A FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE VICTIMS NEED TO BE MADE
WHOLE [inaudible]
OUR RATEPAYERS SHOULDN'T TAKE
THE RESPONSIBILITY THE BIGGEST
HIT FOR THIS THE SHAREHOLDERS
THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AND
SO. FOR ME I THINK WE'VE DONE A
GOOD JOB AND I THINK WE CAN GET
THERE WHEN IT COMES TO THE IT
COULD ENVIRONMENTAL ECOLOGICALLY
SOUND APPROACH WE MAY HAVE SOME
DIFFERENCES BUT I THINK WE CAN
COMPROMISE AT IN INCOME OUT WAS
SOMETHING WE CAN ALL LIVE WITH.
THIS IS THE ISSUE IS THE
SECURITIZATION ISSUE THIS IS THE
ISSUE WITH THE P. YOU SEE.
AND I FOR ONE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
A PASS TO THESE COMPANIES
RETROACTIVELY I DON'T GIVE A
PASSED TO THEM GOING FORWARD BUT
I THINK WE NEED TO SET UP SOME
GUIDELINES.
AND THAT IS THE FRAMEWORK I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US ALL OVER
THE NEXT.
I PROBABLY TALKED FOR A FULL
HOUR SO THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE
HOURS THAT ARE LEFT SO THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD --
BUT HOLD THOSE ACCOUNTABLE WHO
NEED TO BE PROTECT THE VICTIMS
THE RATEPAYERS TO THE EXTENT WE
CAN AND I THINK WE'RE REALLY
CLOSE.
AND SO I HOPE THAT OVER THE NEXT
FEW HOURS WE CAN SUSPEND.
THAT'S SORT OF ARE
INTRACTABILITY WE SOMETIMES FEEL
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT HERE IF NOT A WE HAVE
FAILED THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
WAS OF ANY OTHER.
SENATOR DODD AND THEN --
DISTRO.
YOU KNOW FOR THE VERY BEGINNING.
YEAH WE TALKED ABOUT.
CURED IS ASIAN --
IN IT YOU KNOW IN THE OUR
DISCUSSIONS ON THE SENATE SIDE
WE FELT LIKE.
YOU KNOW A SCRIBE.
I TO CAST [inaudible]
INDEPENDENT AUDIT --
OF P. GENIE WOULD BE NECESSARY
--
TO TAKE THE MAXIMUM OUT THAT
THEY COULD ABSORB [inaudible]
BEFORE [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW.
ABSOLUTE DOWNGRADES --
THAT WOULD REALLY IMPACT THEIR
RATE PAYERS BEFORE --
SITUATION LIKE BANKRUPTCY.
AND I TALKED ABOUT TRYING TO
FIND SOMEBODY SOME INDEPENDENT.
VOICE FINANCIALLY IN THE MARKETS
TO OPINE ON WHAT'S REAL AND
WHAT'S NOT.
BECAUSE THIS THIS DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY I THINK IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
MONEY MANAGERS.
THERE WE'RE BOTH LONG AND SHORT
I. P. JEANNIE.
AND OF COURSE THE ONES THAT ARE
SHORT ON P. JEANNIE [inaudible]
WHAT THIS?
TRY TO TALK THAT WE HAVE HERE
ABOUT BAILOUTS.
IT THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT THEY
WANT THE STOCK TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE THEY WANT LATER THIS
WEEK THEY HAVE A DOWNGRADE AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THEIR
GIMME PROFITING BY ANY DOWNGRADE
--
OF PGA ON THE OTHER SIDE THOSE
THAT ARE LONG ON PGP THAT A BAD
RPG NAY.
ACTUALLY THERE BOTH SAYING THE
SAME THING THEY AGREE WITH
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN THEY
AGREE THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
IN A BET.
SO THE CONVERSATION UP HERE.
HAS TO BE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT THAT YOU BET DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
IT I AM JUST SO FUHRMAN THAT
AFTER TALKING TO THESE --
HAD THE THESE PEOPLE IT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF P.
JEANNIE GOES BANKRUPT.
LET ME TELL YOU.
ALL THOSE FAMILIES FORTIES FORTY
SIX PEOPLE THAT DIED.
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD.
THE FIVE TO SIX THOUSAND HOUSES
AND BUSINESSES.
THAT DEAD BIRD OF THE GROUT.
WE KEPT THE INVERSE COMBINATION
IN PLAY AND I'M TOTALLY OKAY
WITH THAT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IS THE
VICTIMS
ARE GONNA GET BRUTALIZE COULD BE
VICTIMIZED AGAIN IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO.
THAT WE DO WHAT I SAID AT THE AT
THE UP AT THE TOP OF MY
COMMENTS.
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
NOT TO REPEAT THEM BUT THE LAST
ONE WAS MAKE SURE THAT WE ASK
FISCALLY SOLVENT.
UTILITIES IT'S ABSOLUTELY
PARAMOUNT.
IN MOVING FORWARD.
BUT YOU KNOW.
I JUST WANNA GIVE A COUPLE
THINGS LIKE MICHAEL PICKER SAT
HERE IN FRONT OF US AND SAID I
CAN ASSURE YOU BECAUSE WE'VE
AUDITED P. GENIES BOOKS.
IT I DON'T EVEN LIKE BE IN A
POSITION WHERE I DEFEND THE PGD
PARTICULARLY.
SINCE I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THEY DID MAKE A LOT OF
MISTAKES.
WHEN HE OPINED?
THAT THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY
DID THE HARDENING.
THAT THEY WERE PAID TO DO THAT'S
WE TOLD US RIGHT THERE.
SO I I'M A LITTLE BIT CONFUSE
WHAT I HEAR SOME OF THESE THINGS
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
WE PROJECTED IT FOR THOSE OF YOU
DIDN'T GET THEY THE PRESS
DEMOCRAT THEY'RE OUT OF SANTA
ROSA.
THEY HANDLE THE YOU KNOW THE THE
NEWS AND IN THE STOMACH COUNTY
AREA ALL GROUND ZERO FOR FOR THE
FIRES --
YEAH.
I THINK THAT AREA PROBABLY AS A
RESENTMENT RATE.
PGP HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY A ROUTE BUT THIS
NEWSPAPER SAYS THE PLAN.
THAT ESSENTIALLY IS BEFORE US
TODAY IS NOT A RATE PAYER BAIL
OUT [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
IT'S NOT A UTILITY BAIL OUT IT'S
A RATE PAYER AND VICTIMS BAIL
OUT.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DO THE JOB
HERE AND PROTECT.
IN MAKE THEM PAY AS MUCH AS THEY
COULD POSSIBLY PAY THAT IT'S GOT
TO BE.
THAT THE CONVICTION THAT WE HAVE
THEY'VE GOT A THEY'VE GOT TO
HAVE THE FIRST DOLLAR AND SKIN
IN THE GAME.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT PLAN.
WE LOSE ALL THAT AND AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT ARE VICTIMS.
IT OUR RATEPAYERS ARE GONNA JUST
PAY MORE AND MORE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I CAN ASK
JUST A POINT OF CLARIFICATION OF
MORE INFORMATION HERE.
WE HAVE THIS DOCUMENT.
TODAY WAS FIRST DAY.
WE'VE HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW IT.
AND AS I'VE REVIEWED IT IT HAS.
QUITE A BIT OF VERY TECHNICAL --
LANGUAGE.
AND IT IS --
THIRTY OR SO PAGE DOCUMENT.
ON WHAT IS A PROCESS I MEAN
TONIGHT ARE WE GONNA.
IS CONTINUE ON WITH OUR JUST
GENERAL COMMENTS AT WHAT POINT.
ARE WE GONNA COME BACK OR I MEAN
I'D LOVE TO HEAR WHAT THE PUBLIC
HAS TO SAY ABOUT THIS DOCUMENT
BUT I I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'D
HAVE PROBABLY.
HAVEN'T SEEN AT WAR HAVEN'T HAD
A CHANCE TO THOROUGHLY REVIEW
WHAT.
I ALSO LIKE TO HEAR FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SEE WHERE
THEY ARE ON THIS DOCUMENT.
I THINK GENERALLY WHAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED GENERALLY ISN'T HERE.
I CAN SAY THAT.
WITH SOME CERTAINTY BUT THE
DEVIL'S ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS.
AND AND I MEAN THE CLOCK IS
TICKING AND WE HAVE A WEEK.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
THOROUGHLY DISCUSS ANY ITEM THAT
MAY.
RAISE A CONCERN OR NOT BE VETTED
THOROUGHLY.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS WHAT WE?
WHERE WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE
TONIGHT?
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
[inaudible]
ENOUGH --
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO US TO
GET INTO THE DIRTY DETAILS HERE
FROM HERE [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP HERE
WE GONNA COME BACK TOMORROW AND
WE CAN --
TAKES HER TESTIMONY AT SOME
POINT THERE ARE NO IF YOU CAN
SOROKA.
HELLO ATTEMPT.
TO THIS DOCUMENT.
FIRST OF ALL IT IT'S A PRODUCT
THAT -- HAS
HAD SOME EVOLUTION FROM WHEN WE
HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT --
YESTERDAY EVENING AND WE SPENT
ABOUT THREE HOURS AS A AS OUR
ASSEMBLY CONFEREES KIND OF GOING
THROUGH IT AND HAVING A CHANCE
TO GET.
TO A CERTAIN DEGREE OF COMFORT I
THINK THAT AS A RESULT OF THAT
THERE WERE --
SOME THOUGHTS AND IDEAS OF WHAT.
THE NEXT STEP MIGHT BE IN TERMS
OF OUR REACTION TO IT.
ARE I DO THINK --
CLEARLY.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM [inaudible]
BECAUSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY AND
ALSO FROM SELLING AMAZES FOR
REACTION TO WHAT THEY SAW AND
GIVING A ARE THEIR REFLECTION IN
THEIR PERSPECTIVE OF HOW IT
MIGHT BE MASSAGED --
SILLY RADIUS HAS IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF AREAS AND THIS --
GIVING THE DIRECTION TO P. YOU
SEE AND WHAT.
TOOLS MIGHT LOOK LIKE IN
LANGUAGE AROUND THAT THAT AND
THEN THERE'S SOME OTHER AREAS I
DON'T WANT TO LIMIT IT TO THAT
THAT.
SHE IS A SHARED WITH WITH OUR
STAFF FOR THEM TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION --
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN COMMUNICATIONS NOT
ONLY WITH WITH OUR SIDE BUT I
BELIEVE THROUGH --
SENATOR --
OF MIKE MAKE CULTURE --
SENATOR DODD.
AND SO TOMORROW I THINK THE IDEA
IS TO BE ABLE BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN. TO TAKE COMMENTS FROM
OTHER MEMBERS.
A AND THEN TRIED A FASHION.
SOME TYPE OF A DIRECTION
OBVIOUSLY SENATOR DODD AND I
WILL.
HILL WORK WITH THE THE SENATE
CONFEREES AND OUR WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY CONFEREES WILL GET
TOGETHER AND WE'LL --
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN SORT OF PULL
TOGETHER THE FINAL PIECES.
THERE ARE STILL SOME OTHER PARTS
OF THIS THAT STAFF IS IN THE
PROCESS OF WERE SMITHING --
BUT I DO.
BELIEVES THAT WE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I THINK
THE GOAL IS FOR US TO COME BACK
TOMORROW.
WITH THE PRODUCT THAT WE CAN.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO HAVE IT'S ACTUALLY IT WOULD
BE A VOTE BUT IT'S ESSENTIALLY.
HAVING MEMBERS SIGNED ON TO THE
CONFERENCE REPORT.
AND SO YOU'D HAVE THREE WHAT'S
ESSENTIALLY YOU HAVE HAVE THREE
MEMBERS FROM EACH --
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
OR FROM ITS DELEGATION TO TO
SIGN ON TO THEN MAKE IT.
IT'S WAY TO THE FLOOR.
AND THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THAT WOULDN'T UNFOLDS OF
THREE SENATORS AND THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
SIGN ON THEN.
THEN THE A CONFERENCE REPORT
MOVES FORWARD FOR THE FOR BOTH
BODIES TO TO REVIEW.
AND AT THAT POINT IT BECOMES
UPPER DOWN VOTE.
ON THE MATERIAL NOTHING COULD BE
AMENDED AT THAT POINT
[inaudible]
SO.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW WHERE WE WE
THIS PART OF THIS PROCESS IS
JUST TO CONTINUE TO BE
TRANSPARENT TO SHARE WITH THE
PUBLIC.
WHERE WE ARE AT THE TIME THAT WE
GET THERE AND SO THIS IS STILL A
WORK IN PROGRESS YOU'VE HEARD
MEMBERS CHARACTERIZE IT IN?
A VARIETY OF WAYS OTHER SOME WHO
HAVE NOT YET COMPLETELY READ IT
--
THE OVER ARCHING GOALS I THINK
ARE CONSISTENT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY VERY HARD
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PRODUCT THAT WE CAN BRING FORTH
--
FOR TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND AND THEN I'M GONNA I'M TO
RECOGNIZE SUMMER DOLLY.
UNCLEAN WOULD AND THEN IF I
COULD I'D LIKE TO TURN TO THE
PUBLIC.
KEEP IN MIND THE CLOCK IS
TICKING ON US AND SO --
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU REALLY HAVE
SOMETHING THAT YOU NEED TO
SHARE.
OUR EACH PERSON.
HE THAT HAS NOT BEEN SAID OVER
THE LAST MONTH.
OF THEN YOU HAVE A MINUTE TO TO
MAKE THAT --
THAT COMMENT SO WILL WE WILL
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO
WISH TO TO MAKE A COMMENT BUT
AGAIN.
IF YOU REALLY.
REALLY FEEL THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO HEAR.
AT ALMOST TEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
WHEN THE CLOCK IS TICKING?
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO
GET TO CLOSURE ON THIS.
THEN WE WILL BE HAPPY GLAZER
LATER.
AND THEN WE'LL BE HAPPY TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS.
YEAH APPARENTLY HAD NO IMPACT.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WANT TO JUST OUT SO MAYBE A
LITTLE PERSPECTIVE FROM.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATED BY --
BIPARTISAN WORK SINCE THEY HAVE
BEEN HERE AS YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE BE BIPARTISAN
IF YOU'RE GONNA GET A BILL
THROUGH THIS PROCESS --
BUT IS SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH.
ACROSS THE AISLE ON FORESTRY
ISSUES.
AND FOR SOME REASON THAT I JUST
WANT TO THROW THIS OUT THERE
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S WE THE STAFF.
TO DO WHAT WE ASK THEM TO DO.
SENATOR WOULD NOT I HAVE HAD
LANGUAGE OUT [inaudible]
AND IT'S SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE GETS MESSED UP AND IT THE
STUFF WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
REASONABLE.
IT'S NOT WE PUSHED BACK THE
OTHER DAY WHEN THERE WAS TALK
ABOUT CUTTING. THIRTY SEVEN INCH
TREES ARE SOME CRAZY STUFF AND
WE'RE NOT ASKING THAT WERE
ASKING.
FOR GOOD SOUND POLICY TO BE PUT
IN PLACE IT'S ACTUALLY USEABLE
AND SO I JUST WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT THIS THAT.
AS MY FRIENDS ACROSS ON THE
OTHER SIDE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE A
LOT OF INFLUENCE ON ON STAFF.
THAT THEY TAKE THIS LANGUAGE IN
SERIOUSLY INCORPORATED INTO THE
BILL'S BECAUSE IT IS GOOD POLICY
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING TO SEE.
WHEN YOU'VE DONE BIPARTISAN WORK
ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND AT THE
END?
THE LANGUAGE GETS PUT IN AND
THEN YOU'RE FORCED TO TOMORROW
IF THE LANGUAGE IS A RIGHT THAT
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE YOU THEY'RE
GONNA VOTE WITH IT.
AND ACCEPT WHAT WAS THERE OR
YOU'RE GONNA NOT AND I'M THAT'S
WHAT I THINK IT'S BEEN A
FRUSTRATING THING FOR ME OVER
THE YEARS IS THAT.
YOU WORK YOUR BILL THROUGH TWO
HOUSES AND AT THE VERY LAST
SECOND SOUTHERN CHANGES WHERE
IT'S NOT USABLE ON THE GROUND
THAT WAS MY POINT SO I WOULD
JUST.
ASK THAT YOU HELP.
US SHEPHERD OUR LANGUAGE THROUGH
AND IT STAY INTACT MY MIND IN I
KNOW AND IS SIMILAR WHAT'S MINE.
JUST GOOD POLICY AND WILL WORK
THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'LL I'LL BE BRIEF AND A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT I JUST WANNA I
WANNA.
POINT OUT THAT I DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT BEFORE AND ONE IS THAT --
AND I AND I RECOGNIZE THE
COMPLEXITY AND AND I DO NOT
BEGRUDGE ANYBODY WANTING TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT THESE THINGS ARE
ABSOLUTE ACCURATE.
BUT WERE ONE OF THE REASONS I
HAVE BEEN US.
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT NOT WANTING TO
CHANGE THE RULES REGARDING TO
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES
IS THAT. FOR THE TWO LARGEST
FIRES WE DON'T HAVE THE FINAL
REPORTS.
AND IT TROUBLES ME THAT WE COULD
MAKE POLICY DECISIONS THAT COULD
HAVE LONG RANGE A FAX.
BY CHANGING THE RULES GOING
FORWARD WE HAVE RULES IN PLACE.
AND AND AND I THINK --
BARRING THE THE OR PARRIS OF
THESE REPORTS AYE I JUST AND
HAVE A HAVE US HAVE A REAL
DISCOMFORT IN MAKING.
MAKING DECISIONS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY CHANGE --
THE LANDSCAPE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
HIM AND THEN FINALLY I WON IT
WITH -- YOU
KNOW LOOK MIGHT MY ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTING RECORD --
IS VERY VERY VERY STRONG AND I'M
VERY PROUD OF MY ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTE MONEY RECORD.
HIS OWN WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE POTENTIAL CHANGES.
THEY'RE NOT EASY DECISIONS FOR
ME THEY ARE NOT IN ANY WAY EASY.
AND I I I WOULDN'T.
ORDINARILY CONSIDER SOME OF
THESE SOME OF THESE THINGS WERE
IT NOT.
FOR THE STATE WE FIND OUR LAND
IN AT THIS POINT.
CLEARLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
IN SOME AREAS FOR ALONG TIME
ISN'T WORKING.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE.
THE COMBINATION OF THINGS THAT
HAVE BECOME SO INCREDIBLY
DESTRUCTIVE SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THOSE POINTS AND AND I DO
HOPE THAT WE COME.
TO A RESOLUTION HERE WE COME
WORK FOR IT AND AND NONE OF THE
HOPEFULLY THIS THAT THIS DOESN'T
LAST FOREVER [inaudible]
I FRANKLY.
OKAY WE'LL TAKE OUR FIRST THANK
YOU FOR THAT WE TAKE OUR FIRST.
OF SPEAKER ONE MINUTE FOR
EVERYONE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE TIME
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN HOLDEN
CHAIRMAN DODD MARK JOSEPH ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
ONE ADDRESS WHAT'S BEEN REFERRED
TO AS THE CAP OR THE SKY
DISTRESSED TESTED THE SCRUB.
IF YOU TO TO GO TO THE
BANKRUPTCY THERE A LOT OF LOSERS
BESIDES THE SHAREHOLDERS.
AS YOU POINTED OUT VICTIMS WILL
NOT GET PAID THEY WILL HAVE THE
MONEY TO REBUILD --
RENEWABLE ENERGY CONTRACTS
ANOTHER GENERATION CONTEXT WE
CANCELED BIOMASS PLANTS WON'T
HAVE CUSTOMERS.
AND AT THE END THAT THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT WILL PRESENT
RATEPAYERS WITH A BIG BILL AND
THAT WILL BE A BIG INCREASE IN
RATES.
PAGE ME MAYBE AT FAULT FOR THESE
FOR THE FIRE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND IF SO.
SHAREHOLDERS SHOULD PAY.
THE ABSOLUTE MAXIMUM THEY CAN
PAY WITHOUT HARMING CUSTOMERS.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE COMMITTEE
FOR TAKING EVERY DOLLAR THE
SHAREHOLDERS CAN GIVE WITHIN AN
INCH OF THEIR LIVES WITHOUT
HARMING THE BREAK A SECOND.
I SAY THAT AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF EMPLOYEES OF THAT COMPANY.
THAT'S NOT A BAIL OUT OF P.
GENIE THAT'S THE BEST THING FOR
REPAIRS.
MY LAST FIVE SECONDS AT ONE
ADDRESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH
QUESTION ABOUT NUMBERS AND
SECURITIZATION.
THAT THAT'S YOUR TIME.
I'M IT IS I'M SORRY.
NEXT BIGGER AND AND JUST SO I'M
CLEAR.
THE FACT THAT THIS LINE GOES ALL
THE WAY AROUND ARE THESE PEOPLE
JUST STANDING AROUND TO WATCH
OTHERS TALK ARE YOU.
LOOKING TO SPEAK AS WELL NO OKAY
THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENT --
ABOUT --
OVER FORTY PUBLICLY OWNED NOT
FOR PROFIT ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
PROVIDE ELECTRICITY TO ABOUT.
25% OF THE STATE.
JUST ONE ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE
WORK THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
DONE SO FAR AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE DIFFERENT INTEREST YOU HAVE
TO BALANCE JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT ONE SECTION FORTY ONE FOR
PUBLICLY AND UTILITIES REQUIRES
THEM TO DO.
A NEW WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON PRESERVING SOME OF THE
DISCRETION UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
PUBLIC AND UTILITIES HAVE. TO
DETERMINE THEIR WILDFIRE RISK IN
THEIR SERVICE TO THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PUBLIC AND UTILIZE
RUN THE STATE WITH VARYING
LEVELS OF WILDFIRE RISK.
URBAN UTILITIES UTILITIES AND
CENTRAL VALLEY AND AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT. TWELVE
HOURS TWENTY FOUR HOURS ON
REFINING AT LANGUAGE PRESERVE A
LOCAL CONTROL WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE PLANTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
PATRICK CALABRO UP FROM THE
ASHES I AM A VICTIM.
I LOST MY HOME.
I ALMOST LOST MY LIFE IN THE
TUBS FIRE.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE OTHER VICTIMS AND COPY PARK
IN AND TO TERA COUNTY IN SANTA
BARBARA.
SO I MEASURE THIS PACKAGE BASED
ON WHAT IT DOES MEAN FOR
VICTIMS.
DID YOU CARE TAKE CARE LIABILITY
RIGHT FOR THOSE VICTIMS SO THEY
CAN BE RESTORED YES YOU DID.
DID YOU START IS A SUB PACKAGE
THAT CAN.
BEGIN TO PREVENT I'LL USE THAT
THEY ADEQUATELY HARDEN THEIR
GRID.
AND NOW THANK YOU SENATOR DOT
FOR PUTTING THE ADDED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THOUGHT A
LACK.
YES YOU DID.
IS A STARTING WHO WE GOT A LOOK
BEYOND THAT AND WITH --
SEWING AND WOOD AND DOLLY THE
TALK ABOUT FIRES GO WAY BEYOND
THAT WE GO 90% OF FIRE FIFTEEN
SO THIS IS A GOOD PACKAGE IN
DOING THAT.
AND DID IT.
IS IT.
FOR RATEPAYERS AND IS IT OUT A
CLEAN DRESSING THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF P. GENIE THAT'S FOR
YOU TO DECIDE.
WE THINK IT'S YOU'RE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND THAT THIS
CAN PROTECT RATEPAYERS AND
PROVIDE SOME STABILITY FOR THE
UTILITY TAKE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHAT
YOU MAY HAVE TO STAY ASSOCIATION
ELECTRICAL WORKERS ACCOUNT
WEDNESDAY PATRIOTS COUNCIL WAS
UC'S COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS
--
WE SUPPORT THE PACKAGE THIS
BEFORE YOU DO WE AGREE WITH --
SUMER DOLLY AND WOOD THAT IT
COULD BE IMPROVED ON THE FORCE
YOU SITE WE DO --
DO WE THINK THAT WERE CLOSE ON
THE SIX IS THERE SOME IS THERE A
LITTLE MORE A ROOM FOR
NEGOTIATION THERE IS AT THE END
OF THE DAY IF WE DON'T INSURE
THAT THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
IS SECURITIZED WORKERS --
OF VICTIMS AND REPAIRS CAN BE
DAMAGE TO YOUR POINT MISTER
WOULD IF TODAY SOMEHOW.
PGD COULD GET FINANCING.
THE DIFFERENCE TO RATEPAYERS
BETWEEN WHAT WOULD.
WHAT WOULD COST RATEPAYERS FOR
THEM TO GO OUT AND GET FINANCING
AT THE RATES THEY CAN ACHIEVE
IT?
AND A SECURITIZATION FOR EVERY
BILLION DOLLARS YOU SECURE TIES
YOU SEE REPAIRS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM WHAT IT WOULD COST PGD
TODAY TO GO OUT OBTAIN THAT DEBT
TOMORROW THEY PROBABLY WILL BE
ABLE TO OBTAIN THAT DAY SO WE
URGE YOU NOT TO VOTE ON THIS
PACKAGE OR SOMETHING VERY CLOSE
TO IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YES MONEY JOHNSON THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS --
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD US A LAST
WEEK ABOUT THE CASCADING EFFECT
OF INSOLVENCY IN A PART OF
UTILITIES WE THINK THIS PACKAGE
IS MOVING THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HOLDING UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE
LOVE FOR WHAT THEY ARE --
WHAT LATEST HAPPENED --
AND I HAVE --
TO UNDERSCORE WHICH SENATOR DIED
IN THE ABOUT THAT AS A WAY TO
BASICALLY FINANCED NOT ONLY THE
THE POTENTIAL LIABILITY OUT
THERE BUT A BIT ALSO LEAVE THE
FOR OUR RATEPAYERS I'LL GET GET
THAT TAKING CARE OF ITS
APARTMENT THE VICTIMS GOT A
TAKINGCARIBS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
AND TO PREVENT RATE SHOCK FOR
THE RATE PAYERS SO WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO MOVE FORWARD I CAN ASSURE
YOU YOU'RE KEEPING PEOPLE IN NEW
YORK UP THE FIRST THING I READ
TODAY WAS AN ALICE REPORTS SAY
THAT THE BIGGEST FEAR PEOPLE
HAVE.
IS PEOPLE NOT ACTING AT ALL HERE
THAT THAT THAT THIS SOMEHOW DOES
NOT END UP IN MOVING FORWARD SO
--
IT IS A GOOD PACKAGE THAT YOU
pWILL SEE A PRODUCT SOMETIME
TOMORROW THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
TRACY HANSEN AND HERE TONIGHT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE METROPOLITAN FIRE CHIEFS.
I AM A RECENTLY RETIRED FIRE
CHIEF AS A MATTER OF FACT I
WOULD IMPLORE YOU TO CONSIDER
INSERTING LANGUAGE AND THIS BILL
THAT INCORPORATES THE
AUGMENTATION OF MUTUAL AID.
ON YOUR AYE KEY ELEMENTS LIST BY
JUST FROM LAST FRIDAY THERE WAS
A MENTION OF EXPANDING THE
PURPOSES OF THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT TO INCLUDE.
OTHER USE OF EXPANSIVELY USING
PRE POSITIONING FOR FIREFIGHTERS
AND EQUIPMENT --
PREVENTION IS CERTAINLY KEY
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT CERTAINLY
KEY BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
FIRES IN THE JOB OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OF PREVENTION'S GONNA
TAKE SEVERAL YEARS ARE JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER.
INSERTED NOT MITCHELL A LANGUAGE
AND NOT LOSING SIGHT OF THE
BENEFIT OF MAKING THAT HAPPEN
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP WERE IN
SUPPORT OF FINANCING THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LIABILITIES KNOWS
GOING FORWARD WE HOPE THIS IS
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL REPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUST MULLIN FOR A SERIES THAT
BUSINESS NATION STATE IN SUPPORT
OF SUSTAINABILITY.
GENERALLY SUPPORT THIS PACKAGE
TO BELIEVE THAT A BALANCE OF
STABILIZE ASIAN AND COST
RECOVERY WILL BE THE BEST WAY TO
ENSURE THAT WE KEEP THE CLEAN
ECONOMY GOING.
THAT WE MAKE A VICTIMS HOLE AND
TO HOLD THE UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
BOOK OR ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION PART OF THE RATE
PAYER --
WORKING GROUP THAT'S BEEN
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES.
CLEARLY WILD FIRE VICTIMS ARE
PROTECTED BY THIS AND WE THINK
THAT THAT'S FULLY APPROPRIATE
INSURERS ARE PROTECTED.
THE TRIAL ATTORNEYS ARE
PROTECTED LABOR'S PROTECTED.
SHAREHOLDERS ARE PROTECTED AND
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS ARE FULLY
EXEMPTED FROM ALL COST RECOVERY
SO THEY'RE PROTECTED.
BUT WE'RE STILL NOT SEEING IS
THIS MYSTERIOUS PROVISION THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
THAT IS GONNA HOLD SHAREHOLDERS
RESPONSIBLE ONE SOMEONE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S NOT IN
THE DRAFT THAT WE GOT TODAY WE
HOPE IT SHOWS UP.
IN THE DRAFT THAT'S COMING
FORWARD THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN RISLEY SUCH AS WHAT THE
WESTERN SEAS PETRON ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER BOOK ADORE
JUST MADE --
WE ARE REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE
BUT STILL WE BELIEVE THAT
CERTAIN KEY PROVISIONS ARE
MISSING FROM THE BILL WE CAN'T
WITH THE UTILITIES OFF THE HOOK.
AND READY TO PROTECT REPAIRS
SOMETHING YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
SAW CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
ARE WE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE LANGUAGE
AND I WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION --
TO FATALLY IS PAGE THIRTY SIX IN
THE MIDDLE OF PAGE --
THE LITTLE SEE --
DO WORD DISCUSSES --
THE WHAT I BELIEVE IS THAT WHAT
THIS DOES SENATE AND CHAIRMAN
HERE DODD WOULD DESCRIBE AS THE
STRESS TEST.
BOB CORRECT --
THERE ARE NUMBER OF COMP NEVER
POINTS.
NOW REGARDING FINANCIAL STATUS
CONSIDER --
DISALLOWED TO BE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD
DRAW ATTENTION TO THIS IS BEING
ILL DEFINED ARE NOT DEFINED
CLEARLY.
IN THIS LEGISLATION IS TO WILL
AS TO HIS DRAFT AS TO WHAT THAT
MEANS.
WHAT IS IT WHAT WHAT ARE THE
DISALLOWED IN WHAT IS WHAT IS IN
THE AGGREGATE ME DOES THAT MEAN
THAT UTILITY --
IMPRUDENT --
COSTS COULD BE CUT WE COULD BE
ENCOMPASSED IN THE SECURITIZED
ACOSTA WOULD BE THEN PASSED ON
TO RATEPAYERS.
I ONCE WE'VE DETERMINED WHAT
THIS QUOTE UNQUOTE STRESS TEST
ALLOWS.
THE STATE TO TAKE OUT OF THE I
USE IN TERMS OF A A COST YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S WHAT GOES WITH
THAT GETS PASSED UNDER REPAIRS
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE ACCESS
THAT'S NOT OUT HERE.
AND WE WOULD ALSO ASK THANK YOU.
THE SYSTEM YEAH IT IS ESTIMATED
ONE THANK YOU SHOULD DO IT THANK
YOU.
YEAH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS JOINT COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA'S PANIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE REPRESENTING OUR OVER
SEVENTY CHAMBERS A MEMBER
CHAMBERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SOME OF
THAT THAT ARE HERE TONIGHT --
I I YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING.
ARMED ALL ALONG BOMB.
WELL ON BEHALF OF OF OUR
CHAMBERS FOR THE COMMITTEE
ADOPTED COMPREHENSIVE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL MAINTAIN FINANCIAL
STABILITY UTILITIES HERE IN THE
STATE ARE WE SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE JUST BEFORE YOU AND
WE'RE OPEN TO THE FOUR POINT
PLAN.
THEY ARE HEALTHY UTILITIES ARE
CRUCIAL TO FOR OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
DEPEND ON THE CREATION OF
CONTRACTS JOBS POWERED BY
RELIABLE SAFE ENERGY.
GREEN JOBS GRANT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STARTLING DISADVANTAGED
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN TO BECOME
HIGH SKILLED.
OUR WORKERS AND OUR PRIORITY FOR
DIVERSE GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
PRESERVING THE ECONOMIC HEALTH
OF A UTILITIES MEAN PRESERVING A
VALUABLE PARTNER FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS A SUSAN DRY AND ON THE CO SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY SPANKS HIM OF
COMMERCE.
SOME HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
JULIE CANETTI I REPRESENT OVER
THREE HUNDRED BUSINESSES IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN AREA THAT REPRESENT
OVER SIX THOUSAND JOBS.
AND I WE'RE HERE SUPPORT OF THE
PLAN IS PRESENT IT AND I DO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT --
DISSOLUTION AS PRESENTED HERE I
MUST ADDRESS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHILE
FARS ALLOWED VICTIMS TO BE PAID
A PROMPT AND AND I ADEQUATE
MATTER SO AGAIN I'M HAVE SMOKING
GUNS SPANISH CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE'S.
WE'RE SUPPORT OF THE PLAN
[inaudible]
THE GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ANGIE GARY I'M WITH THE FRESNO
AREA HISPANIC FOUNDATION.
THE FRESNO AREA HISPANIC
FOUNDATION SUPPORTS THE PLAN
PASSED OUT TONIGHT.
HEALTHY UTILITIES ARE IMPORTANT
TO OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
LIVELIHOOD. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ISSUES NEED TO BE SOLVED AS PART
OF THIS PACKAGE ALSO OPEN TO THE
FOUR POINT PLAN MENTIONS I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NATHAN ALONZO
WITH THE FRESNO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS.
REPRESENTING OVER SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND JOBS IN.
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY WE
SUPPORT THE LANGUAGE IT'S BEEN
PASSED OUT TONIGHT AND WE ARE
OPEN TO THE FOUR POINT PLAN THAT
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED BY MEMBERS
HERE TONIGHT --
OR LOCAL COMMUNE FRESNO DEPENDS
ON STABILITY IN AFFORDABLE
ENERGY IN ORDER TO EXPAND TO
PROVIDE MORE CALIFORNIANS WITH
JOBS.
AND ARE SITTING COUNTIES
PROJECTED TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF
JOBS IN ECONOMIC SECTORS IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
IN AND NEW AND WE NEED NEW AND
RELIABLE ENERGY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
AND WE NEED THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT ADDRESSED IN THIS
LEGISLATION SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GOOD EVENING PAT FOCUS SHE'D I'M
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIA PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE.
I REPRESENT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
ASIAN BUSINESSES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE FOUR POINT PLAN.
I BELIEVE SENATOR DODD SAID IT
BEST.
THAT WE MUST HAVE FINANCIALLY
HEALTHY AND STABLE UTILITIES SO
THAT RATE PAYERS ARE PROTECTED.
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT WE
BELIEVE THAT IS TO BE TRUE.
WE REPRESENT THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
THE MOST NOTABLE DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE BELIEVE WE NEED AN ABSOLUTE
STABLE UTILITY INDUSTRY IN ORDER
TO BE.
PROTECT THE REPAIRS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING WE ANY TALK AT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE LANGUAGE
AS OUTLINED FOR SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS WHO COULD NOT BE PRESENT
NIGHT.
THEY INCLUDE TMK ADMINISTRATIVE
CONSULTANT HAPPINESS INK JTS P.
INK MOVE CONSTRUCTION YOU AND US
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY ATLAS
INSPECTION AND TESTING AND
LITTLE POTATO INK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE WHEN
IT IS FRANKLY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE SECULAR ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ADOPT THE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL MAINTAIN
FINANCIALLY STABLE UTILITIES FOR
OUR STATE.
PRESERVING FINANCIAL STABILITY
IS A FINANCIALLY STABLE
UTILITIES IS IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS COMMUNITIES AND SHARED
ENERGY FUTURE.
ANY SOLUTION THAT DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES WILL THREATEN THIS
FINANCIAL STABILITY LEAD TO
HIGHER ELECTRIC RATES AND
THREATEN OUR CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRESS.
PRESERVING THE ECONOMIC HEALTH
OF OUR UTILITIES MEANS
PRESERVING A VALUABLE PARTNER
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
WE COMMEND THE AND WE COMMEND
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND THE BUSINESS SECTOR THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SCHUESSEL JACK ALSO REPRESENT
THE ASIAN CHAMBER --
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
SECULARIZATION OF PROGRAM.
AND DIE WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THE
BOND PROGRAM THAT --
THAT'S IN PLACE --
WILL CERTAINLY HELP --
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY --
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
CLAIMS I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THAT PREACHING PGD IS A CO A%
INCURRED.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE DOPE ONLY
HAD APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF INSURANCE COVERAGE.
SO THEY SHOULD OF CERTAINLY HAD
BETTER COVERAGE ON THEIR
INSURERS --
PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING OFFICER HERNANDEZ
SOME WE HAVE OF TURN ADVOCATES
FOR RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYERS.
HEARTENED BY THE DISCUSSION IN
THE COMMENTS.
BY ALL OF YOU WHO WANT TO
PROTECT RATEPAYERS AND ONE IN
SURE.
THAT UTILITIES ARE LIABLE FOR
THEIR MISDEEDS FOR THERE PRUDENT
BEHAVIOR NEGLIGENT BEHAVIOR.
APPRECIATE THAT.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT HOW DO YOU
DRAFT THAT IT'S VERY SIMPLE?
THAT'S CURRENT LAW.
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN THIS
DOCUMENT [inaudible]
CHANGES THAT.
I CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU WOULD
WANT THE LEGACY OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE.
A CHANGE. TO THAT TO HOLDING
UTILITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR BEING
NEGLIGENT OR BEING IMPROVED.
PAGE THIRTY SIX SUBDIVISION SEE
DOES JUST THAT IT PUTS A CAP.
ON HOW MUCH UTILITIES WILL HAVE
TO PAY FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BALANCE OF LIABILITY FOR
NEGLIGENT BEHAVIOR WOULD GO TO
RATEPAYERS SECURITIZED ARE NOT
THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
ARE GOOD EVENING JOHN R. IAGO BE
HAVE THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES LATINO CAUCUS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
EFFORT AND TIME YOU PUT INTO IS
A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN ONE THAT UP
PROTECT LOCAL GOVERNMENT A
WHETHER PROTECTS RATEPAYERS.
ARE BUT ONE THAT YET KEEPS A
HEALTHY UTILITY OUT BUSINESS
NEED WHAT THEY FOR THE SERVICE
THEY PROVIDE THANK YOU.
NOT CLUB SCENE ON BEHALF OF SMUD
EYES WHEN I THINK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK WE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS WITH
THE NEWEST DIVERSION LANGUAGE
THAT WE'VE SEEN.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS SMART ANOTHER
PO USED TO ALIGN THE STATE
REQUIRED WILD PLOT WILDFIRE
PLANNING EFFORTS WITH FEDERALLY
REQUIRED PLANS --
THAT CODE SECTIONS REMOVED UNDER
THIS -- BILL
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO HOPEFULLY GET
THAT ADDED BACK IN --
ALSO WE HAVE SOME CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE AROUND THE BIOMASS
PROCUREMENT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT IT IS WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST CAMERON'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THANK YOU FOR THIS
PUBLIC PROCESS AND YOUR HARD
WORK INTO IT THAT WE HOURS OF
THE EVENING --
THANK YOU FOR TAKING IMMERSED
CONDEMNATION OFF THE TABLE OUR
GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO PROTECT
COUNTIES --
ARTIST AND OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF FIRES BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TOOLS TO
ENSURE FOR A SAFE AND STABLE
UTILITIES TO PROVIDE ELECTRICITY
TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
I AM WE UNDERSTAND THAT ONE OF
THOSE TOOLS CAN BE
SECURITIZATION LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
USE THIS TOOL TO SPREAD OUR DATA
OVER TIME.
IT CAN BE DONE IN A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WAY THAT PROTECTS
REPAIRS THAT PROTECTS VICTIMS
AND KEEPS OUR UTILITIES
FINANCIALLY STABLE WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS PACKAGE OR
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR.
SANDY DEAN UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE CHAIRMAN OF MEDICINE
ONE HUMBLE REDWOOD COMPANY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND ACRES
OF FOREST LANDS IN THE STATE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THAT FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
I ALSO LOST A HOUSE IN THE TUBS
FIRE.
AND I HAVE TO AREAS OF COMMENT
THE FIRST IS THAT THE BILL
ADDRESSES FOREST EXEMPTIONS FOR
PAINTINGS.
AND THE PRESCRIPTIONS AND THAT
OUR DREAM FORESTRY 60% CANOPY
COVERAGE INCREASE AN AVERAGE
DIAMETER OF THE STAND.
BEEN SAVING THE LARGEST TREES IN
THE STAND THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON ALLOWING THOSE
THINGS TO OCCUR IN TERMS OF ROAD
LINKS AND SO ON AND I URGE YOU
TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE THOSE
KINDS OF RESTRICTIONS.
THE THINNING PROGRAM AS IT
OUTLINED IN THE BILL WAS
EXCELLENT.
THE SECOND IS ON BIOMASS OF THE
SUPPORT FOR BY MASS IS GREAT BUT
IT LIMITS ELIGIBLE FORCE FUELS.
TO A FUEL IT COMES FROM A
FITTINGS FROM EXEMPTIONS AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY MODEST.
THIS BIOMASS BUSINESSES A SCALE
BUSINESS THAT NEEDS
PREDICTABILITY IF YOU WANT TO
WORK YOU'VE GOT TO INCLUDE MORE
FUEL THE BEST WAY WOULD BE TO
LOOK AT THE FRAPH.
MAPS ON FIRE VULNERABILITY THANK
YOU.
GETTING IN THIS JUROR NO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU MY NAME'S CHRIS MARS
AND I'M OF THE ARE CAN YOU
SERVICES.
OUR COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION.
RENTS ARE LOW INCOME.
AND REFUGEES WE SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE PRESENTED IN OUR OPENS
WITH A FOUR POINT PLAN.
I WOULD BELIEVE THAT FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE UTILITIES ARE OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
ANY SOLUTION THAT DOES NOT
REALLY ADDRESS ACOSTA SOARED
ASSOCIATED WITH LASHES WILDFIRES
WILL LEAD TO AN INCREASE BURDEN
TO CUSTOMERS AND THREATEN OUR
CLEAN ENERGY OUR PROGRESS.
WE ENCOURAGE VERSION
LEGISLATURE'S PUT SOFTARE LA
SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
PROMPT PAYMENT.
OF VICTIMS OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SOME TO KNOW WILDFIRES --
PLEASE ACT NOW AND ADOPT A
SOLUTION TO PROTECT VICTIMS AS
WELL AS OUR ENERGY FUTURE THANK
YOU.
I RECORDED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION ONE THANK
THE CO CHAIRS OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HARD
WORK.
ALSO PREDICTING ONE THANK GOD
CENTER JACKSON FOR CALLING OUT
THE HUMAN FACE OF THIS ISSUE
TONIGHT.
AB I CAN'T IMAGINE A MORE
COMPLICATED SET OF ISSUES THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO DEAL WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
LIABILITY GREENHOUSE GAS.
GOALS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
UTILITY VIABILITY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORKER SECURITY
FIREFIGHTER SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
LET ME ADDRESS THE FORESTRY
CONCERNS.
AND SIMPLY SAY THAT THE OF
COURSE HE COMPONENTS HAVE BEEN
WELL NEGOTIATED.
AND AS YOU WORK TOWARDS FINAL
LANGUAGE I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO LOOK TO THE TWO EXPERTS ON
THIS COMMITTEE MISTER WOOD AND
MISTER DALI.
WE ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK
CLOSELY AT SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
ON THE SUNSET DATES BECAUSE
THERE HAVE TO BE FORCED --
BOARD RULES PUT IN PLACE AND
THAT THE THIS SUNDAY DATES MAY
BE TOO SHORT.
ON THE BIO MASS WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LOOK AT BROADENING WHERE
THE FUEL LOADS CAN COME FROM SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY DO GOOD
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AND MAKING SURE THOSE CONTRACTS
ARE LONG ENOUGH.
FINALLY GOD WE SUPPORT TED THE
OF THE ONGOING AND CONTINUING
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME STAN ROGERS
OF THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS A
PRESIDENT CEO THE RANCHO CORDOVA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I REPRESENT
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND A SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS THIS
EVENING WE DO SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE AND WERE OPEN TO THE
FOUR POINT PLAN THAT PRESERVING
FINANCIAL STABLE UTILITIES.
IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS OUR SHARED
ENERGY FUTURE.
WE REQUEST THAT ANY SOLUTION
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCES THAT WILL
THREATEN OUR FINANCIAL STABILITY
WILL LEAD TO HIGHER ELECTRIC
RATES AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
PROGRESS ON THE STATE'S CLEAN
ENERGY EFFORTS WE MUST NOT WAIT
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE ON
BEHALF OF OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND OUR RESIDENTS.
WE ARE TO YOU ACT IMMEDIATELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
AARON EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES OUT WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THE GENERAL
DIRECTION THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
TAKING IN TERMS OF CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE TO MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE TRANSPARENT
PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE UNDERTAKEN
TONIGHT AND IN THE PREVIOUS
WEEKS AND I WILL ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM C. SAC.
A WITH REGARD TO THE PACKAGE AS
WELL AS URGE YOUR INCLUSION OF
THE MUTUAL AID LANGUAGE AS
REFERENCED.
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THINK.
UP MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION I AGAIN WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF A
FINANCIALLY HEALTHY UTILITY. TO
THE ABILITY OF FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY TO CONTINUE TO FILL UP IN
THE STATE --
I DO WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE SECURITIZATION PIECE THAT IS
IN THE PACKAGE RIGHT NOW.
AND ASK THAT ANY FINAL PACKAGE
INCLUDE OUT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS DANIELLE
MILLS ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CAUCUS WHEN I
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK --
THIS EVENING AND ENCOURAGE YOU
TO KEEP MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION
--
WE DO I URGE YOU TO FIND US OF
FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FINANCING IN
SECURITIZATION AND ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT UTILITIES ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO BE STEWARDS OF THE
GREAT MOVING PORTRAIT THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DELANEY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION ARE
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS FOR SOLAR AND
ETF RENEWABLES.
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
RENEWABLES CALLING.
THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS GET ALONG
WITH OUR UTILITIES BUT THAT'S
THE SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR INDUSTRIES THAT LED
CALIFORNIA TO BE A WORLD LEADER
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT WE
CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT EACH OTHER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
I MY NAME IS ANDREA DIVO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CUENTA
SERVICES THE LEADING INTEGRATED
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS
PROVIDER.
WITH THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIAN
PLOY IS MANY DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THE WILDFIRES WE SUPPORT A
PLAN THAT WILL ENSURE A STABLE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO A FINAL
PRODUCT ACCOMMODATING FOR SUCH
STABILITY THANK YOU.
NO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CARRY HALF BAKED NEXTERA ENERGY
RESOURCES WHERE LARGE RENEWABLE
ENERGY DEVELOPER IN THE STATE
WITH EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH P.
JIMMY AND ADDISON.
BRING COURAGE BY THE DIRECTION
OF THE COMMITTEE AND
PARTICULARLY THE FOCUS ON
SECURITIZATION AS A LOW COST
MEAN TO MEANS TO FINANCE.
UMPIRE LIABILITY AND MOVE
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
UTILITIES TO BE FINANCIALLY
HEALTHY AND TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT INVESTMENT.
IN CLEAN ENERGY.
GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KAREN MAUREEN MILLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION REPRESENTING FAMILY
FARMERS.
AND RANCHERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMPLEXITIES
--
FACED AND WHAT THE DRAFT
DOCUMENT REPRESENTS AND WHERE
CAREFULLY REVIEWING --
AND WILL STOP FOR A REVIEW THE
CONTENTS OF IT M. IS YOU AS WE
DO CONSIDER IT.
I WANTED TO UNDERLINE A COUPLE
OF POINTS THIS EVENING AND ONE
IS WITH RESPECT TO THE RATE
PAYERS AND AS YOU EXAMINE.
IT AND CONSIDER DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS TO UNDERSCORE THAT
RATEPAYERS IN FACT SHOULD NOT
TIME.
TAKE THE ONLY HIT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN DETERMINING THE COST
AND ALSO TO POINT OUT THERE HAS
IT UNDERSCORES WAS POINT OUT
THAT WORDS DO MATTER.
AS WHATEVER DOT.
THE DOCUMENT IS CREATED THOUGH.
INTERPRETATION WILL MOVE OVER TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND WORDS WILL BE CLOSELY
SCRUTINIZED AND WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON HOW.
THE EFFECT REALLY DOES.
FLOW THROUGH THE RATE PAYERS
THANK YOU.
WHO CO CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
PRESSMAN YANNI ON BEHALF OF
CLICK A CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS?
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
HEARD TONIGHT FROM ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REGARDING.
AT THE VICTIMS --
HARDING AGREED TO PREVENT FUTURE
CATASTROPHES AND PROTECTING
RATEPAYERS TO PUT A FINER POINT
ON A MISS MILLS ANNA COMMENTS
WORDS DO MATTER.
AND WHILE THE LATEST DRAFT
DOESN'T LEAN TOWADS MORE RATE
PAYER PROTECTION.
THE PROCESS OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IS QUITE
ARCANE.
I AND WORK LACEMENT AND HOW
THINGS ARE DRAFT THAT ARE GOING
TO BE SCRUTINIZED AS SHE SAID.
AND WE WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP YOU WITH
WITHOUT DRAFTING MOVING FORWARD
AND I IN THE HOUSE ON BEHALF OF
THE RATEPAYERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRIAN
WHITE FOR THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE
FORCES ASSOCIATION AND THE FORCE
LANDLORDS OF CALIFORNIA THE
TELFER LICENSE FORCED
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE ACTUAL
EXPERTS.
WERE THE BEST PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS WILL BE SIGNED OFF ON
ALL THE TIMBER HARVEST PLANS WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
MISTER CHAIRMAN ON PUSHING THIS
ISSUE.
FOR AND PARTY LIKE TO THANK OUR
SIMILAR DOLLY AND SOMEONE WOULD
FOR KEEPING OUR ISSUES THE
CENTER.
I THINK MISTER DALI HIT ON THE
KNOWN HEAD IS THAT PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING WE WANT THESE ISSUES
JACQUI WORK TO ADDRESS FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
IT RIGHT.
OUR SOME THINGS IN THE IN THE
BILL THE CURRENT DRAFT THAT
CAUSES SOME CONCERN BUT WE ARE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC.
THE BILL WILL ACTUALLY HELP DEAL
WITH FORCE MANAGEMENT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THE SMALL AMHERST
CANNOT AFFORD SOME OF THINGS
THAT ARE BEING CALLED FOR IN
SOME THE BILL.
LANGUAGE VERTICALLY ARTISTS
ABOUT PAGE.
TWENTY SIX AND UP IT'S DEALING
WITH THE WORKING FORCE
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
CURRENTLY THERE'S A LOUNGE FOR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ACRES THIS BILL
WOULD DROP DOWN THE TEN THOUSAND
ACRES.
WILL LIKE THAT CHANGE SO THAT IT
WITH EXISTING LAW SHOULD BE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ACRES.
ALSO WITH THAT WE AGAIN WE'RE
COSTS UPS MISTER CAN WE THANK
YOU FOR LEADERSHIP.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
JACK ON BEHALF OF VARIOUS
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS IN THE
STATE -- I
FIRST JUST LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALIAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
DOLLYWOOD PLANNING FOR PUSHING
FORWARD WITH --
PREVENTION AND ONGOING FIGHT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE HUGE
COST THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN TAKING CARE OF OUR FORESTS
AND WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
FOR SO THAT WE'RE NOT CONTINUING
TO TALK.
ABOUT THESE LAW LARGE COSTS THAT
ARE ENDING UP ON REPAIRS --
I WAS LIKE THE THINK THE
COMMENTS ABOUT NOT GOING
BACKWARDS AS REPAIRS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT EXPRESSLY
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
COSTS OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ARE YET.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE IT HAS REPAIRS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT TAKING ON THOSE
COSTS WITHOUT KNOWING THE FULL
PICTURE --
SO AS YOU MOVE FORWARD WE JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT THE RATE PAYERS
CAN TALK TO CONTINUE TALKING
ABOUT.
THOSE IMPACTS TO THEM AND HOW TO
PROTECT THEM MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY FAN HELP OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS SEAT AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
DEFERRED TO OUR COMMENTS MADE IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS BUT WOULD JUST
LIKE TO REITERATE THAT WE HOPE
THAT MAYBE I CAN WORK TO FIND
SOLUTIONS ENSURE THAT I USE.
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO COMMIT
TO A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
THINKING.
MARK WHITE EVEN ON BEHALF OF AYE
H. AYE POWER SERVICES ONE OF THE
LARGEST BIOMASS PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE I WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN CHAIRMAN DIED.
ASSEMBLYMAN DOLLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PIECES OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
I WILL SAY THAT THERE IS A I
THINK A TECHNICAL GLITCH IN THE
LATEST LANGUAGE ON PAGE.
SIXTY AND EXCLUDES BIOMASS
PLANTS THAT ARE IN NON
ATTAINMENT ZONES YOU'RE GONNA
EXCLUDE BIOMASS PLANTS ARE
PROCESS SEEM.
HIGH HAZARD ZONE FUEL TODAY
CLEANLY.
IF YOU KEEP THAT LANGUAGE IN
THERE WE THINK THAT LANGUAGE IS
TO BE EXCLUDED OTHERWISE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS AND
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
WHO'VE TAKING YOUR TIME TO BE
HERE AND FOLLOW US THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
I THINK THAT --
LESSER SOME CLOSING COMMENTS FOR
MANY MEMBERS I THINK WE ARE
[inaudible]
MR.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I
DIDN'T KNOW --
IF WE'RE GONNA SPENDING MORE
TIME THIS EVENING GOING OVER
SOME OF OUR COMMENTS AND I KNOW
THAT.
THE LAST TIME WE DID THIS THEM
COURSE IT IS QUITE LATE COME.
BUT I THINK THIS IS OUR LAST
TIME TO BE ABLE TO GET TOGETHER
AS A GROUP BEFORE WE WE FINALLY
SEE.
A C. LANGUAGE --
I DID HERE. FOUR POINT PLAN OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
MAYBE WONDER IF MAYBE AS A FEW
FOLKS GOING OUT TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOUR POINT PLAN --
BUT I REALLY DO THINK IT
ENCAPSULATES A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS DUMB AND ACTUALLY THE
SOLUTION.
OF FOR MANY OF THE THAT THAT
THAT THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE SOME CONVERSATION
AMONGST.
THE COMMITTEE IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE DOWN THAT ROAD
TO MAYBE MAKE SOME CHANGES IN
THE LANGUAGE [inaudible]
I I YOU KNOW I'VE WE'VE WE'VE
TAKEN A YOU KNOW ON OUR SIDE
WE'VE REALLY.
WITH THIS PLAN THIS BEFORE US
TONIGHT --
IT KIND OF GOT A LITTLE BIT
BACKWARDS WHERE WE WANT TO BE
BUT YOU'LL COMPROMISE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE --
WE NEED TO BE FOR OUR RATEPAYERS
AND ARE IN OUR VICTIMS.
AND WITH THAT IN MIND I WANTED
TO BRING UP --
ONE METRIC FOR RATEPAYERS. FOR
EVERY BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
SECURE TIES.
IT'S FIVE DOLLARS AND TWENTY
CENTS A YEAR FOR A RESIDENTIAL
RATEPAYERS.
SO EVEN UP TO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
OVER TWENTY YEARS EVEN IF ID YA
EVEN IF IT WAS FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR HIT AFTER TAKING.
ALL WE CAN GET FOR P. GENIE.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE.
YOU KNOW TWO DOLLARS AND TWENTY
CENTS A MONTH OR TWENTY FIVE
BUCKS -- A
YEAR FOR RATEPAYERS WITH WHICH I
THINK YOU LOOK I'D RATHER NOT DO
ANY BUT TO GET TO A DEALS TO
MINIMUS I WILL SAY THAT THIS
FOUR POINT PLAN.
KIND OF TAKES US BACK A LITTLE
BIT FROM OR WANTED TO BE IT AT
THE BEGINNING BUT I AM OPEN TO
THIS AND I THINK IT'S A A
REASONABLE --
PLAN GOING FORWARD THAT I THINK
THAT -- YOU
FIRST OF ALL WE WE'VE GOT TO
GET.
THE DALAI --
YOU KNOW WOULD --
CHANGES IN THIS PLAN I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK WE LOSE
OUT.
WE LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY GET THAT
IF WE DON'T.
A BIT ON THE FORCE THREE THE
SUNSET DAYS OF BROUGHT BY
BROADENING BIOMASS THEY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
I I I WOULD SAY I WOULD SUPPORT
--
YOU KNOW MOVING THAT DIRECTION
IF WE HAD.
A CONSENSUS ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AS WELL.
SO.
IT TAKES CHAD I THINK THIS IS
HEALTHY SO I WILL I WILL JUST
SAY YOU KNOW.
DOCTOR WOULD JULY IN THE SAND
ALL DRY LAWN IN THE FOREST WE
THEIR SOMETHINGS APT TO HAPPEN
IN THIS BILL NUMBER --
ONE WE NEEDED THERE THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT SAYS YOU
CAN ONLY TAKE BIOMASS OFF OF DID
THE STREAMLINED IT PROCESSES OF
THAT'S CRAZY WE NEED TO TAKE IT
FROM EVERYWHERE IN THE WHOLE
STATE IS GONNA BERNICIA TO THE
MAP TO THE DAY.
WE WILL TAKE UP FROM HIGH FIRE
ZONE THREAT --
THERE'S TECHNICAL FIXES IN OUR
LANGUAGE THAT NEED TO HAPPEN AND
I WANT TO HAVE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE GO WITH THOSE I GUESS
WE'VE SUBMITTED THOSE OF MY
STAFF HAS WORKED WITH THE SENATE
STAFF.
AND AND THE ASSEMBLY STOP BUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME PUSH BACK ON
THOSE AREAS THAT ARE REALLY
CRITICAL TO MAKE THIS THING WORK
SO I GUESS FOR ME --
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I I NEED TO
GO WHAT WITH MEMBERS TO GET SOME
HELP.
TO SEALED THE DEAL BECAUSE ME
DOCTOR WOULD AND I ARE VERY OUT
OF IT THAT IF YOU IF AND WE AND
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN IT.
HAS NOT BEEN AT THE LEVEL NEEDS
VIA.
SO WE NEED TO SAY SOMEWHERE IN
HERE THERE WERE GONNA PUT THE
FUNDING IN THERE THERE'S AMOUNT
WE'RE GONNA GET IT FROM
SOMEWHERE --
WE'VE WE'VE PROPOSED GDR F. NICE
MENTION THAT MY OF FIRST
COMMENTS --
GENERAL FUND TO ME I DON'T CARE
WHAT WE GET IT THERE'S THE
STATE'S GOT PLENTY OF MONEY
RIGHT NOW FOR LOTS OF THINGS.
AND THE NUMBER ONE THING THIS
FACING THIS WHOLE STATE IS FIRE
AND WE NEED TO WE NEED TO FUND
THIS AND SO.
HELP ME FIGURE OUT WHERE WE GO
TO GET THAT RESOURCE AND DOCTOR
WOULD I IF WITH THE BUT THE
BIOMASS FIX WE WE THAT WE ADDED.
FIVE FIVE YEAR CONTRACTS.
WE NEEDED FUNDING AND THEN WE
NEED A FEW TECHNICAL FIXES I
THINK THE SENATE --
STAFF WAS STARTING TO COME
AROUND -- TO
YOU KNOW THAT THAT.
WE NEED SOME DIRECTION I GUESS
OF WHERE WHERE WE GET THAT
RESOURCE.
OF OWE ANSWER ONCE SURE I JUST
WANTED TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THERE IS A LOT MORE IN IN THE
FORM OF WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
IN IN ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
THAT WE NEED.
TO BE AWARE OF IT AND KEEP IN
MIND AS WE GO FORWARD THIS BILL
DEALS WITH VERY SPECIFIC ISSUES
BUT ON THE WHOLE PREVENTION
ISSUE -- I
GOT A BILL S. B. TWELVE SAY IT
DEALS WITH --
CONTROLLED BURNS BRINGING CAO
FIRE AND STATE.
OTHER FEATHER AND FEDERAL LOCAL
AGENCIES TOGETHER TO WORK ON
FIRE MANAGEMENT.
I DO THINK THAT THERE HAS BEEN
MONEY --
ALLOCATED FOR THAT SO AS WE LOOK
AT AS WE LOOK AT THIS IS IT'S
MORE THAN JUST A SINGLE BILL.
AND THERE IS MORE THAN JUST A
YEAH YOU KNOW A VERY LIMITED --
FUNDING MECHANISM THERE HAVE
BEEN -- I
THINK IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET AND
PERHAPS GOING FOR WE COULD FIND
SOME OTHER RESOURCES FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. TO DEAL WITH A AYE
BROADER --
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THESE
WE'VE GOT THAT THE ISSUE OF A
BIOMASS BUT WE ALSO HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF OTHER TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX SOME OF WHICH ARE BEING
FUNDED SO.
I THINK IT'S A IT'S A BIGGER
CONVERSATION --
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE NOT THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE THIS ANY MORE
COMPLICATED THAN IT IS BUT JUST
AS WE THINKABOUT THIS.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS GOING
ALONG A GOING ON THIS WELL NOW I
JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN LIFE
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK IT'S
ALSO SHOULD BE NOTED THAT WE HAD
ONE OF OUR HEARINGS A
PRESENTATION OF ALL THE BILLS
THAT ARE ACTIVE THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO REFERENCE THAT I
THINK APPROPRIATELY CONNECTED TO
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
OF THIS NOW I THINK PROBABLY THE
BEST WAY I CONNECTS.
SIR FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND I THINK WHAT'S BEEN
AFFECTED TO THIS POINT IS WHEN.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET EVERYONE
AROUND THIS TABLE --
TOGETHER AT ANY ONE TIME YOU
KNOW HAVING ANOTHER.
OF POSTED MEETING SO WHAT'S BEEN
AFFECTED I THINK WAS WHEN THE
SENATE CONFEREES WERE WORK
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE CHAIR.
AND ASSEMBLY CONFEREES AND I
THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT.
WERE WERE SORT OF NARROWING DOWN
IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING VERY CLOSE TO THAT BUT
WHATEVER OUTSTANDING PARTS.
THAT WE NEED TO IDENTIFY THEN --
SENATOR DODD AND I CAN GET
TOGETHER AND AND SORT OF MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE MOVING
APPROPRIATELY --
WITH THE APPROPRIATE STAFF
BECAUSE ALSO.
THERE IS COMMUNICATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT --
THAT THOSE CHANNELS STAY OPEN IN
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO ACCESS --
FEEDBACK THAT WAY SO I THINK.
WELL WE NEED TO FIND OUT WHERE
IT IS THE LANGUAGE AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S MOVING IN THE WAY THAT
--
WE ALL --
ANTICIPATING THAT IT WILL AND
THEN SENATOR DODD CAN.
SHARE INFORMATION WE CAN GET
TOGETHER AND FIND OUT WHAT --
OUTSTANDING ELEMENTS BECAUSE A I
KNOW A NUMBER OF YOUR MEMBERS
FOR THE FIRST TIME I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READ THE DOCUMENT
SO TO THAT EXTENT THEY MAY HAVE
SOME COMMENTS TO SHARE WITH YOU.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE GOAL IS
FOR US TO RECONVENE AS A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
AND HAVE A FINAL DOCUMENT THAT
WE CAN.
A TAKE ACTION ON TOMORROW.
BUT I GUESS THE GOAL WOULD BE TO
TRY TO DO IT IS EARLY IN THE DAY
AS WE CAN BUT YOU KNOW WILL HAVE
TO WORK WITH THE CONSTRAINTS
THAT WE HAVE --
BUT CERTAINLY --
NO LATER THAN.
WE HAVE TO DO IT EARLY.
CONSPIRACY EARLY AS WE CAN.
SO IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
YES -- IS
ACTUALLY SENATOR STONE THE
BROUGHT THE SUPPER EARLIER AND
I'VE NOT SEEN THIS IN THE
LANGUAGE BUT IN REGARDS TO A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
I THINK FIVE YEARS IS MUCH --
TOO EARLY I WOULD THINK AT LEAST
TEN YEARS IF NOT --
IF NOT LONGER SO AGAIN I HAVE
NOT SEEN THAT LANGUAGE BUT IF
SENATOR SENATOR CORRECTIVE IS A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
ON THIS I DO BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO
BE AT LEAST EXTENDED HER AND I'M
NOT SURE WE HAD A LEAD ON A
SUNSET OF THE NEEDS OF SOARED.
IT'S IN THE LANGUAGE THAT WHICH
WHICH PIECE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
--
OKAY [inaudible]
GOT IT.
I GOT IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
RATHER THAN A FIVE YEAR ARE YOU
LOOKING AT THE SUNSET FOR THE
ENTIRE BILL.
WHO CLOSER SAYING I THINK IN IN
REGARDS TO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROVISIONS I'M NOT SURE THAT ANY
PART OF THIS SHOULD BE AND IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
FOREST.
MANAGEMENT ORG OR FIRE
PREVENTION I THINK.
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET IS JUST TO
TOO EARLY I THINK TEN YEARS
SHOULD BE A MINIMUM I DON'T KNOW
WHAT PARTS.
THAT THERE'S FIVE YEAR BUT I
WOULD THINK THAT TEN YEARS IT
SHOULD BE A SHOULD BE A MINIMUM
AGAIN I THINK.
THAT DEPENDING ON HOW IT'S
CRAFTED BUT FIVE IS JUST SEEMS
TO BE TOO SOON.
IT'S AT PAGE THIRTY ONE OF THE
FIRST DRAFT FROM LAST NIGHT.
JUST BEFORE SECTION.
TWENTY FOUR IT'S REFERRED TO
SECTION.
TWENTY THREE IF I COULD --
MEMBERS I THINK IT.
REFER COULD HAVE I THINK WOULD
BE MORE EFFICIENT IF WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN OPERATE I THINK
GATHERING THE INFORMATION IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
MEMBERS.
AND ALSO FROM THE PUBLIC I THINK
WE TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WE CAUCUS.
AND THEN --
WILL GET BACK TOGETHER OF THE
TWO CHAIRS AND AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S MOVING WITH THE
STAFF'S.
SO THAT WE CAN SHEPHERDED ALL
THE WAY THROUGH [inaudible]
THE OKAY.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER COMMENTS